je vais m'ouvrir le chat on est
tranquille he de toute façon on est
hyper pépous de chez hyper pépous on va
passer 6h ensemble devant devant ces
speed chest ah ça y est les caméras
arrivent va fallir tout recadrer mais je
vais attendre la fin de la première
partie pour savoir dans dans quel sens
ça doit être mis euh attendez ouais
parce qu'en fait je vais devoir tout
changer ouais ça ça a tout ça a tout ça
a tout changé les gars donc on va on va
on va on va prendre ouais on va pour le
moment rien faire on va laisser une
partie se dérouler en fait
et on verra
après attendez je m'ouvre le chat au
passage et puis on va suivre ce petit
match tranquille he parî qu'hier poser
des questions euh n'hésitez pas à poser
des questions je sais pas si vous êtes
déjà arrivé je sais pas s'il y a des
gens qui vont venir d'ailleurs tiens ça
c'est une bonne question est-ce qu'on va
avoir des spectateurs aujourd'hui c'est
possible que
non euh attendez j'arrive pas à me
détacher le
chat je galère un peu non je vais je
vais passer je vais passer autrement
donc je pense que le match va commencer
comme je disais moi j'ai commencer au
dernier moment parce que j'attendais
l'autre caméra je crois que le match est
parti du cou der
j'attendis de tout bien mettre nhésitez
pas à écrire dans le chat s'il y a
personne qui écrit ça peut ça peut aussi
être pas écrire dans le chat ça peut
aussi être rurant en tout cas le chat il
est là ça peut aussi être
rurant le chat il est là ouais j'avais
j'avais un truc
d'Inception et le match ben écoutez je
crois qu'il va partir on va suivre
fan voilà le match il est là et on va
regarder ça tranquille et salut à fur F
bar voilà le match qui part et comme je
vous disais je mettrai les caméras juste
à la fin après la première partie au
moins on saura qui en haut qui en
bas j'ai un problème avec le timer
bizarrement
hop voilà comme ça le timer on l'a et on
est parti pour 6h de
bonheur allez ça change les pièces
normalement Wian est beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup plus forte on verra si elle
s'entraîner elle va gagner facilement
normalement
normalement bon ben ça joue contôle la
case 4 voilà on est on est là on est
bien hop ça échange pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas échanger tiens
hop on attaque un peu le pion
E4 bon on ne sait pas on ne sait pas ce
qui va se
passer on ne sait pas mais salut à de
bière bonjour la France salut à toi
comment ça se passe votre pause
déjeuner comment ça se passe
bien ou
bien salut Enigma boomer déjà de pub
solid oh les petites pub qui partent ça
ça fait
plaisir ça ça fait plaisir les petites
pubs ça fait plaisir je crois qu'il y en
a une minutes toutes les 10 minutes
quoi ça c'est bien ça ça se présente la
petite pubasse qui part bon c est des
deux qui pose problème elle veut pas
faire des sy sûrement à cause de dame
G4 ah ben voilà il y a un peu de gens
dans le chat on va PIR un peu discuter
du
coup ça réfléchit malheureusement je
vous ai pas mis les cam su je pense que
ça va pas bouger ça a l'air d'être bien
je vais pouvoir récuper cam tiens au
moins ça m'occupe aussi au passage euh
ok je vais faire ça maintenant parce que
là c'est vrai que c'est c'est vrai qu'on
a le temps en fait
euh tac tac
tac on va on va aller
choper attendez hein comme ça a été tout
décalé en fait j'avais fait un truc et
ça a tout été décalé évidemment ça va me
prendre un poil plus de temps à cause de
ça
ok donc une cam je l'ai récupéré je vais
récupérer la
deuxième le A3 était magique oh bah
oui voà on peut en avoir bah hier on
avait des trucs encore plus magiques he
dans les matchs on a eu des dames en un
on a on a eu des belles choses aussi on
a eu un mat en un raté on a eu un mat en
de raté on a quand même eu eu de la
belle chose hier aussi
he
ah
attendez on va espérer que ce soit
bon on va espérer que ce soit bon ah
ouais donc je mets pas les noms encore
et tout parce qu'on sait jamais dans
dans quel sens ça va être en vrai
je suis pas passé depuis un moment ça
fait combien de temps ah non c'est que
pour ces streams Camano mais là tu
passes pas pour le honnêtement tu passes
pas pour le meilleur truc là si tu es
pas passé depuis un moment et que tu
passes pour ce match c'est c'est un peu
dommage quoi honnêtement c'est un peu
dommage Capano 95 parce que du coup
c'est tu vas pas repasser pendant
longtemps après c'est c'est terrible en
fait c'est
terrible
c'est terrible bon là il y a un pion de
plus du coup pendant que je faisais le
cadrage des cames
ouais ça ça turboroll hein je crois côté
euh côté
noir ça turbo
troll il a fait fou D6 d'ailleurs dans
les bonnes nouvelles je l'ai j'aiai déjà
dit hein mais je le répète il y a le
il y a la sub battle leag qui va
commencer la semaine du 5 juillet ça ça
va être sympa
ça ça ça va être très
sympa ça va être dans les dans les trucs
intéressants à à
suivre et là il ro c'est quoi les sub
battle
compliqué à expliquer si tu connais pas
complexe à
expliquer interdit de gâcher les
munitions bah oui on pourra rien gâcher
ouais non la sub battle League il y a de
plus en plus d'informations qui arrivent
qui confirment le début imminent le fait
que ça ça ça ait lieu c'est sûr mais il
y a de plus en plus
de d'informations qui qui qui qui
confirment la date du 5 en fait
ouais non ça va être cool il va y avoir
je crois c'est 8 journées de championnat
et après un play-off les quatre premiers
demi-finale finale en espérant que qu' a
une chaîne américaine bien connue qui ne
se défile pas parce qu'il était il était
inscrit mais il n'a pas confirmé encore
son
inscription on a grand
espoir
de prendre notre
revanche ça dépend comment ça joue côté
adverse ple le début de l'event on va
voir on va voir pas sûr pas sûr qui joue
ce serait une grande déception 5 je suis
pas sûr que ce soit bien ça laisse 5
prend6 prise et cavalier qui
su DESS
oh fait une partie de merde pour
commencer la joueuse
chinoise on aura des rles pour éviter la
je sais pas comment ils vont éviter hein
il y aura forcément de la triche mais
bon après nous toute façon on sera bon
esprit hein je pense qu'on est on fait
partie des équipes bon
esprit FEM tu peux aller voir mon
interview sur Chat today où j'en
parle je sais pas si tu sais mais is les
candidats la phrase d'on stream c'est
aller Maxime ouais faudit changer ça sur
chesscom remarqueer Maxime pourquoi
pas allez Maxime quand
même allez Maxime dans tous les cas
ouais pourquoi
pas c'est toujours
valable bon B ça va gagner pour pour les
blancs
pion de plus après ça peut troll ça peut
troll encore la dame est attaqué en un
faut-il le voir
Maxime je pens c'est toujours valable
c'est c'est une phrase de requin j'ai
envie de faire un montage photo
[Musique]
avec Team team blit stream avec avec les
trois invités que qu'on ne voit jamais
enin qu'on voit souvent mais mais qui ne
se montre jamais j'ai nommé Jeff piégos
marlou Brando et Didier barbelet oh un
petit cavalier F3 qui ne sert à rien
mais qui fait
peur bon ok en fait elle veut pion prend
tour prend D5 cavalier prend dame G5 roi
Hin dame prend D5 c'est r mais c'est
relou après c'est R de CHR et il y a roi
H1 aussi qui peut être jouable parce que
la dame protège
H2 c'est génial ou fan une elle va faire
dame pr B2 je pense avec idée dame2 mais
il y aura roi G2 qui couvre tout
elle fait dame
FC
menace voà faut trouver un bon coup
cavalier F4 jouer je
pense ça motive toujours les BA avec le
cous à 15 € euh pas tout toujours
Camano en passant excellente vidéo sur
les pépites de Mathieu cornette ouais
elle est cool la vidéo on l'a tourné il
y a un long moment mais la partie est
très
jolie je sais pas si vous aimez ce genre
de de petite partie simple qu'on analyse
en 12 15 minutes
ou si c'est un peu court entre
guillemets allez j'ai s tempo mais
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait ah c'est terrible
de tomber quand même c'est pas possible
tu dois juste faire G5 tempo et tu
reprends F2 au prochain donc on
l'avantage c'est qu'on va pouvoir savoir
pour le score si on est du bon côté non
on est du mauvais côté voilà j'avais
bien fait de hop tac tac et les
noms attendez on va essayer de mettre
les
noms donc du coup c'est bibi
Sarah ah ça
oueva et de l'autre côté c'est
ouifan
hop et ben voilà j'ai rien compris à
cette fin de partie il y a rien à
comprendre t'inquiète t'inquiète il y a
rien à comprendre donc là joue
l'espagnol Jess je crois que c'est D4
ici le coup ça pas l'air de connaître
elle peut perdre en Wian si elle
commence à jouer lentement et à passer
avoir
cliqué on reste sur sa fin sinon vous
avez trouvé super for et peut-être en
faire deux quand c'est aussi rapide oh
non mais on va pas faire on va pas faire
30 minutes non plus c'était celle qui se
fait coaché par Mathieu l'année dernière
non c'était c'était
Sarah
bibi Sara
non ah la petite pause publicitaire oh
ça fait plaisir la petite pub qui part
ça ça fait toujours plaisir la petite
pub petite
pubette c'est plus moi qui gère les pubs
quand c'était moi qui qui gérait les
pubs il y en avait moins oh là
maintenant il y en a qui partent de
manière aléatoire ça me fait plaisir ça
j'aime
bien oh les petites pubs qui qui se
présentent je sais pas si j'aurais pas
mettre sur ma chaîne perso des pubs
comme ça toutes les 10 15 minutes ça
pourrait être une
idée ça encouragerait les gens à sub
terrible je t'ai vu sur interdit
d'interdire c'était cool tuas gérer j'ai
rien interdit hein ouais franchement je
peux ouais franchement
j'hésite
richesse incoming ouais oh voahà je vais
être très très bien pub toutes les 10
minutes le y dans le port de canne d'ici
quelques
semaines mais là c'est pas moi qui
lesgère hein donc euh
juste ça part je crois qu'il doit y
avoir un minuteur et ça doit partir de
manière euh toutes les 10 ou 15 minutes
ça part
ouais le y blit stream serait pas mal
hein
le RS d'ici quelques jours je sors le RS
les li ass
paisse pas de pub aléatoire ah mais pub
aléatoire c'est beau en fait
ouais quand tu peux pas ça en vrai les
pubs ouais c'est vrai que c'est bien
Axel hein les gens te remercient pour
les gens remercient pour leur mettre de
la
pub
bon petite position je sais pas les
pièces noires sont bizarres ici la
tourang8 la dame en E8 mais
bon le temps est mauvais pouran on
pourrait avoir une bibara qui va en
finale aujourd'hui allez
j'annonce j'annonce la surprise bibi
Sara en finale en
demi-finale allez Calif de Bibi
Sara ah ce serait beon une Calif de Bibi
Sara moi j'aime bien le bibi dans son
prénom en fait je crois Murtas m'a
expliqué que son vrai prénom c'était
bibi plutôt le sarah est rajouté
quoi en fait son prénom c'est bibi
j'adore comme prénom c'est un beau
prénom quoi
bibi je sais pas j'aime bien
non ah non c'est parti les joueux jou
leur répertoire à fond et ça peut un peu
moins cliqué au hasard que chez les
garçons bon ça clique au hasard à la fin
en fait mais au début ça clique un peu
moins au hasard
c'est qui la championne des échecs c'est
bibi ah il fa un beau couple avec Fabien
libizevski ouais libi et Bibi quoi bibi
libi céta quand j'étais mon Pascal ah
bah du coup Pascal tu dois être pour
bibi
terrible
bon ça joue he ça place les pièces ça
clique au hasard mais j'aime bien
comment il clique au
hasard j'aime bien les clics au hasard
de Bibi Sarah elle envoie les pièces sur
le roi je sais pas elle se enfin elle
fait ce qu'elle peut quoi elle se bat
quoi pe dame F6 ambulant elle place ses
pièces elle peut pas faire H5 pour le
moment il y a foupran et dame Pr
mais ça va elle joue en ambulant quoi
petite partie ambulante cavalier guno
elle veut renvoyer cliquer au hasard en
G3 elle va peut-être peut-être cliquer
au hasard par là B une petite tourelle
en D8 allez hop on va cliquer au hasard
avec la dame peutêtre en F3 allez il
faut cliquer je pense queifan elle
clique pas assez ça se sent elle clique
pas
assez keV pour info tu as 2,5 contre 0,5
contre B ouais oua j'ai j'ai 2 et demi
un demi ouais mais la dernière là quand
j'ai fait nul je jouais en fait c'est
une partie que je jouis il y a un ou de
jours j'étais complètement gagnant mais
j'étais au téléphone en même temps j'ai
checké un mail enfin je faisais trois
trucs en même temps elle elle était en
mode Entraînement speed chess féminin
moi j'étais en mode répondre à un mail
et un truc pro de de type comptabilité
quoi et du coup j'étais complètement
gagnant mais mais j'ai
raté
mais oui le demi-point est un demi-point
jeté à la
poubelle mais oui bibi Sara normalement
c'est penalty
hein normalement c'est un
penaltyc oua non mais c'était terrible
par que je pourrais montrer la partie
j'étais tellement gagnant
mais le mail pro était trop important
URSAF
W ouais j'ai gâché une demi munition je
suis pas allé jusqu'à perdre mais j'ai
gâché la
munition il est quelle heure en Chine il
doit ça doit être le soir il doit pas
être si
tard bon j'aime bien ça clicote un peu
au hasard de partout je me demande si a
fou prend cavalier H4 qui prend
G2 qu'est-ce qu'elle fait an elle met
elle met une veste qu'est-ce il fait
froid chez elle il se passe
quoi on sait
pas je c'estis pas sûrement ça la ligne
sûrement fou prend puis on prend
cavalier H4 dame prend B7 qui prend G2
mais moi je partirai pour ça sans trop
réfléchir mais après il y a peut-être du
cavalier G4 relou après bibi elle a le
tempsin
l'air sympa ou non
elle a l'air assez coolou je sais pas
elle elle a elle a un visage qui qui qui
dégage la sympathie
ou c'est moi qui est
impression non elle a pas une tê pas
qu'elle dégage un truc
gentil non
l'air gentil
bibi moins non
ouis elle a l'air douce ouais c'est ça
l'air
gentille bibi tu as l'impression qu'elle
est beaucoup plus concentrée elle est
elle est elle est au bout de sa vie
quoi mais elle est concentrée gentille
wi
fan bibi elle est concentrée en mode
tueuse
non
non mais B l'air sypa mais je par là
elle est tu sens que je sais pas elle
dégage une envie de gagner quoi une
détermination ou tu as l'impression
qu'elle est là tranquille à blitzer
quoi bibi je trouve qu'elle l'air
vraiment déterminé tu sais aller
chercher la gagne quoi
ouais c'est de l'analyse psychologique
qui part
ouais l'air vraiment ça vraiment d'être
une gagnante alors fan c'est marrant
elle a été championne du monde et tout
mais elle a l'air
vraiment gentille
quoi Freud en position é plus ah bah
Freud prenez des cours chez moi c'est
très
connu mais ouais ça va troll un côté o
fan ça va perdre autant là c'est sûr
elle gère pas trop sur Internet où
peut-être c'est pas une bonne blitzeuse
he
je pense qu'elle faire fou F8 pour
préparer G4 mettre le fou en C5 et
défoncer les cases noires
ouais
terrible
terrible je vais mettre la caméra un peu
plus comme ça c'est bien j'ai deux cam
je pourrais me faire une inception en
double
cam ouais elle a l'air déta bibi je
pense qu'elle est assez sympa mais mais
quand elle joue là ça se voit qu'elle a
vraiment envie de
gagner oh là là la pointe de vitesse de
de où
orslacer ses
valcheux et c'est bibi qui est mal
autant faites voir le classement en
bulette bibi elle est combien en bulette
oh bibi qui se fait mat en un oh c'est
terrible bibi qui a pris le mat en un
terrible ou qui égalise
terrible
elle a complètement déconné
bibi ça fait mal ça fait voir les
classements bullette donc j'en étais où
26 32 et où 251 ouais ouais non bullette
ça sent que c'est pas trop ça
côté côté où
ouais on en a parlé aussi du mat H5 KML
ça sentait qu'il pouvait arriver mais
bon comme il arrivait pas directement on
s'est dit bon benah il arrive pas il
arrive pas quoi et puis après tout d'un
coup il est il est
parti
oh la petite pub qui repart oh bon ça ça
fait
plaisir robinide vont vas-y c'est ce
soir Camille sera
là Rob robinide qui s'est qui s'est
trompé de chat à mon avis terrible pour
le modérateur oh là
c'est là c'est pas le bon
chat c'est varantes connu ça avec où tu
donnes le pion et après tu joues pour
l'activité ah c'est la pube récurrente
que tu' dit ce soir sera là ah oui
ok c'est c'est la nouvelle pub merci à
Camano 95 du coup qui envoie un prime
pour éviter la pub sur
chesscom bien joué
Camano il je suis r
plus comme quoi ça marche hein je vais
vraiment faire ça sur ma chaîne perso en
fait pub toutes les 10 minutes quoi poum
dans vos gueules
quoi c'est beau quoi ça fonctionne en
fait la
stratégie de full pub
ouais je va t con sub mais
bon c'est un peu abusé
quoi çave de minutes de pub à l'arrivée
REP ouais c'est pub tout le temps quoi
pub de pub
d' c'est
beau la pu c'est bien t les minutes
c'est
ciao c'est beau
hein
ciao super looping qui du coup se
barre bonne bonne journée à toi bonne
journée à toi mec moi en vrai aussi je
me barre des streams s' y a trop de pub
je me barre genre 30 secondes ça va mais
quand c'est deux ou 3 minutes ça me
saoule ça me ça me saoule aussi je ferme
généralementà ça a l'air de d'être
correcte pour les deux hein c'est quoi
c'est pion de plus pour les Noirs mais
activité pour les
blancs
ah la pub Logitech elle est pas mal
ouais
ouais ça dépend de la durée des pubs moi
jusqu'à 30 secondes ça va au-dessus de
30 secondes ça me
saoule la pub Logitech ouais elle était
marrante la première fois elle saoule
maintenant après c'est que moi sur ma
chaîne perso j'en mets vraiment pas du
tout de pub donc ça vrai que j'aurais
peut-être en mettre un peu
ouais quand tu vois le une pub sur 7 ça
trigger de ouf ouais je suis d'accord
bon là ça a l'air d'être cool pour les
noir quand même he j'ai l'impression
qu'ils vont qu'elle va réussir à
roquer donc
F4 elle peut prendre
elle peut pas vraiment prendre le
deuxième pion pour le moment parce
qu'elle a fait le
clouage mais moi non plus j'ai j'ai
jamais la pub Gilette mais c'est
peut-être parce qu'il voit que ma ma
moustache et ma barbe pousse très
lentement je pense tour C8 he va être
joué dame C7 why
not aussi jouable hein truc c'est
qu'elle peut avoir du Grand rock aussi
dans son range même si ça me ferait
peur j'avoue que si tu commences à
lâcher les pues sur ça va sortir les
primes ouais non c'est pas con en vrai
ouais donc ça c'est une varente assez
forcée je me demandais si elle allait le
faire au coup précédent en fait
ok maintenant échange des dames et sur
dame G3 du coup elle pourra faire rock
et sur fou H6 bon alur dame prend H6
quoi en fait c'est juste maintenant que
la dame elle sur la
6e et Gilette leur pub c'est toujours le
même slogan là Gilette la perfection
masculin ou ça a changé depuis le temps
où j'étais matrixé j'ai tellement été
matrixé quand j'étais gamin par cette
pub qui passait à la
télé surtout ce qui est ouf avec ça
c'est qu'en
fait ma femme ma femme prend mon mon
rasoir à chaque fois qu' a qu'elle a
besoin je sais pas pour pour les jambes
ou je sais pas quoi et pas que mais euh
mais en fait mon rasoir
euh une fois sur deux il est il est plus
il est plus là où il doit être
quoi c'est terrible quoi il se il se il
se fait euh il se fait prendre à chaque
fois
quoi c'est ça je comprend pas la prés
masculin parce qu'en vrai
euh en vrai ils sont bien leur leur le
leur rasoir en
vrai
ah ça je fais une petite blague on
rigole un peu
hein il faut
bien faut bien un petit peu rigoler les
amis mais en vrai en vrai ils sont bien
leur leur truc je je je comprends
pourquoi ils font pas un enfin tout le
monde peut les utiliser quoi c'est
pratique ils sont ils sont ils sont
qualitatif
quoi bon là du coup il yir r tour à D1
mais c'est pion de moi pour
euh pourquoi pas pas fou H6 al fou H6
sera un joli coup he ça menacerit mat en
un mais le problème c'est d' prend
H6 après moi j'ai tellement pas de de
moussage et de barbe que je suis même
capable de me raser sans sans
gel
[Musique]
sans mousse à rasé ah j' trouvis
plus le mot parce que c'est du G du coup
le le momous S rasé me revenait
plus donc ça
échange a de sexy sur le commenteur
français non mais juste je vois que
c'est tout le temps parce qu'ils ont une
gamme en fait de de rasoir pour femme
aussi mais mais mais mais j'ai j'ai j'ai
entendu le même le même retour que que
que les rasoirs du coup on va dire
unisexe
sont sont très
bien du coup
euh du coup c'est pour ça que je
demandais si la pub c'était toujours la
même on s'est un peu
perdu
mais bon ça prend toujours un pion de
plus he pour pour les Noirs mais ça peut
être ah il y a peut-être fou C7 t prend
D7
maintenant qui traîne ça traînit
peut-être dans tous les cas en fait ah
mais il y aura dame prend B2 à la fin
non mais il y aura peut-être des fous5
ça peut être dangereux ce pion
G7
propose tour d6ah tour des6 je pense le
problème c'est fou
pr mais bon F5 pourquoi pas ah il y a
pas t prend des il a du mat en C1 et là
c'est bibi SAR qui suit
autant ah B le chat oua la discussion
rasoir me paraît beaucoup plus
fructueuse que que la discussion
échec
F7 attention à ne pas se prendre un
contre sur
F2 qui pourrait faire
mal va peut-être trouver
ça le F qui
part le F F qui part et maintenant la
tour va venir en F8 il a toujours a
prise une fois
elle peut fouger 3 F 3 intermédiair
est-ce que ça marche menace d'amage de
mat t
terrible et ça
tombe je pense que sortir un gros match
maisan prend les
devant
terrible une petite pu là qui part
à la fin de la
partie d'ailleurs les trucs que j'ai à
faire aussi j'ai mon nouveau fauteuil à
monter il y a MSI qui m'a envoyé un
fauteuil pour remplacer mon fauteuil
j'espère leur fauteuil est
bien c'est hyper dur à monter ces
fauteuils je sais pas si vous l'avais
déjà
faità c'est une petite espagnole
toujours G6 F G7 c'est la même que tout
à l'heure c'était pas mal passer pour
bibi et ciao X6 jeanéo ciao à toi passe
une bonne
aprem fait deux pour l'autre je l'avais
monté tout seul j'avais
sué j'avais sué tout seul à le
monter bon c'est la même position que
tout à l'heure quelque chose
près et j'ai reçu mes clés j'ai reçu mes
clés Tour de France aussi oh Tour de
France qui va partirin il va falloir
qu'on se fasse un petit doiner pour se
chauffer après on va on va partir on va
partir en tour de France très très
clairement et je pense qu'on va partir
en tour de France je crois que c'est
exactement la même position en
fait
je pense qu'on va jouer la victoire avec
alaf mais alors je sais pas si je fais
procycling manager ou si je fais Tour de
France 2021 ils m'ont offert les
deux en vrai en vrai ils m'ont faire les
deux mais je pense qu'on doit jouer avec
alaf parce que c'est le seul qui a une
chance de jouer le
général Vlad exceptionnel hier ah bah
oui bon bah Vlad c'est le patron
hein fais faire un comparatif ah non moi
je veux juste faire un arc Tour de
France
hein
euh godu ben godu le problème c'est que
le problème c'est qu'il y a deux contre
la montre et et j'ai peur qu'on prenne
très très cher dans les contre la montre
alors qu'avec alaf on peut essayer de
tenir
après je sais pas s'ils ont rééquilibré
le jeu cette année si les échappées
marchent
mieux al la le coureur montloné oh
robinide qui connaît bien cette région
et Pino il est mort euh non alors il est
encore vivant mais si tu te rappelles
l'année dernière il s'était blessé
pendant le Tour de France il a quand
même voulu le finir et je crois qu'il
s'est défoncé le dos en fait donc là il
courra pas mais il est pas mort quoif
enfin il existe encore
et il y a un Français qui est pas mal là
c'est pé peintre je crois un
jeune qui
[Musique]
peut qui peut être pas
mal pour l'avenir du cycliste français
même s'il a déjà 25 ans il progresse
bien
et Cosne fr ouais Cosne il peut il peut
prendre l'étape par
printre
CNE frroid en vrai il peut prendre une
étape il peut même prendre une des deux
premières étapes CNE
frroid et godu ouais godu il est bon
mais voà il sera leader pour la première
fois sur le
Tour 25 ans si tu encore jeune oui zglub
là tu as raison mais là-dessus tu as
raison mais si tu si tu vois un peu les
les les nouveaux là qui arrivent les les
evenpool pogachar il a que 22 ans
evenpool il a 20 ou 21 ans il y a qui
d'autre dans la next gen cyclisme vous
allez me dire d'autres noms là il y a
Milton aussi qui arrive qui est
jeune Bernal il est un peu plus âgé je
crois il a déjà 26
27 25 peut-être il a 25 Têt Sonic col
Brell gagne les deux premières moi je
vois bien Sonic Nicole brelly en vert la
fin du tour auonor aussi beau coureur
Vlassov il était sur le Giro irchi a pas
monté montré grand-chose cette année
après il peut se réveiller mais il a pas
été très bon cette année
marirchi 24 Bernal ouais non c'est
monstrueux mais oui première étape col
brelly après je pense pas qu'un sprint
en monté il soit il soit vraiment
bon je pense que le sprint la première
étape ça va se jouer à mon avis entre
entre vanart van derpool alaf bien sûr
CNE frroid peut-être au
Conor c'est plus n mais celui qui a fait
qui fait du deè du Giro l'an dernier je
sais plus qui
c'est il y a jack aussi qui va être
dangereux avec la barag cette année à on
AVI faire très attention
à à à la l'équipe Barraine au Tour de
France ah oui oui il était bon
ouais mais Jack eg je crois qu'il a fait
5e du requinet et il est vraiment pas
mauvais à plus tard grim il voir qui
prend H3
ah non OK prend H3 ro H2 ou là oui ou là
c'est la galère là tour à1
ouais non c'est galère là ça s'est mal
passé là ou fan qui a réemployé son plan
du cavalier 5 mais qui l' utilisé
beaucoup plus vite et qui va sûrement
passer à
3-1 bon malheureusement ça va être un
match sans suspense j'en ai bien
peur vous voyez qui tiens venez on fait
les maillots on en reparlera sur ma
chaîne plus tard mais on peut se le
faire là tranquillou vu qu'on a le temps
euh vous voyez qui pour les maillots
genre maillot jaune maillot à poids
maillot vert maillot
blanc ils sont dopé les barrain carouso
2è en Italie Padoun qui s nulle part
écle Brell sur puissant oh c'est aussi
un petit peu pour ça qu'il faut y faire
attention
euh bon ça c'est un peu comme les échec
sur Internet après hein on se doute mais
on n' pas de preuve ça ressemble
finalement le vélo et les
échecs moi je vois bien col Brell
maillot
vert jaune r glitch ouais je suis assez
d'accord godu en poid non godu va jouer
le général VO pas du tout prendre les
poids les poids moi je vois bien soit au
Conor je vois bien à G2R prendre les
poid les poids cette année ou un Barine
attention
Barine je viens de voir porte che INEOS
ça va être lui ou Thomas ou carapace moi
je pense c'est carapace qui va être le
leader de l'équipe même s'il est pas bon
en
chrono Martin à poid possible Martin il
jouera les poids cette année il va jouer
les
étapes
et paraî peintre en poid vous le voyez
pas du
tout Ken Thomas en jaune moi je le vois
pas en jaune Ken Thomas mais après bon
il f prend à 5 c'est la cata ouis dame
C5 ça va très bien échange les dames
elle va gagner à 5 et
C7
parépandre c'est leader de la GR ouais
mais est-ce que tu es vraiment obligé de
de jouer le
général est-ce que tu es obligé de jouer
le général en fait quand tu es dans une
équipe comme
AG2R je suis pas
sûr je peux il peuvent faire une team
sans sans sans jouer le général hein
ouais k pr 5 ça marchait pas il y avait
dame prend et il y avait le cavalier qui
protégeit
des7 général rapporte souvent plus qu'un
maillot à poids ouais mais pour les
sponsors le maillot à
poids est plus intéressant
non donc des4 c'est pas mal ça joue sur
le
clouage dans la notation des coups le X
veut dire quoi et le plus aussi le X ça
représente une prise et le plus un échec
vanp en vert aussi à voir s'il va traver
pour mériter vanerpool je crois qu'il a
prévu de pas terminer le tour parce
qu'il part sur les gios
après moi je vois vraiment bien col
Brell pour les pour le
vert parce que les sprinter en fait y a
beaucoup de sprinters comme cale B one
il y a Arnaud desmar il y a Peter Sagan
il y en a plusieurs mais col brelly
c'est le plus complet il peut leur taper
des sprints mais il peut aussi prendre
les points parce que Peter Sagan il est
pas en méga forme et vanart il pourra
pas vraiment jouer le vert parce qu'il
va être au service
[Musique]
de de primos
il a annoncé hier qu'il le termine V
derpool ah il le termine finalement van
derpool il y a un lien pour ça pour les
poids peut-être un maika euh
ouais pas Rafal maika jouable
aussi crush pas mal en sprint non il
sprinte pas crush vike crush il va
accompagner il va accompagnerlit en
haute montagne démar en ver moi j'y
crois pas démar en vert mais bon il a
impressionné sur le Giro mais le Tour de
France c'est quand même le level
a-dessus il gagnera une étap ou de mais
mais je le vois pas en
vert il va falloir qu'il fasse un bon
début de de
tour il va falloir
qu' démarre
bien
mais le vert van derpool faites voir
vanerpool qui finit le
tour il y a tour C8 à la fin c'est joli
et là fou C3
oh pas
jouer tour à 2 non F B4 ça va gagner
encore un pour fan c'est cool parce que
ça tue un peu le
match il y a pas tour prend B2
attention allez on va mettre la tour
7 pas se faire magouiller quand même
hein
n'importe quoi la finale pouran oh elle
donne une tour en un oh le turbo troll
oh sub battled oh turbo troll
j'ai rarement vu une finale aussi turbo
troller quand même perdre tour fou de
pion de
plus pourquoi tu
joue il y a une
pause non mais c'est fou là si on vient
là-dessus pourquoi tu joues en fait tour
G7 pourquoi tu
joues c'est terrible ça onprend G7 c'est
juste une tour quoi c'est c'est ex comme
ça non non c'est euh ouais turbo troll
dép en plein comme ça je sais pas on
s'en fiche un peu
aussi non non là elle a pas fait exprès
elle a juste pas vu en fait elle a pensé
que sur pr elle avait fousé 3 mais elle
a pas vu qu'elle était cloué en
fait mais ce qui est fou en fait c'est
genre là c'est de pas avoir fait fous 3
ici
faut prend C3 tour prend C3 avec peu de
temps et tu ramènes le roi en en B3 tu
mets le pion H4 la tour en C2 A2 et ça
gagne tout seul en fait il y a quasiment
plus besoin de réfléchir pour gagner
ça et après elle a vraiment galérer
toute
seule bizarre ce
match
oh après on est content de la pause ça
peut ça peut permettre de mettre une
petite pub aussi hein peut être pas mal
une petite
pausette non bon une petite pub une
petite pub
tranquille on va attendre que ça
revienne là de toute façon ça finit sur
des tours en un ça finit sur du méga
trolling he les
parties ça finit pas
sur
sur l'énorme jeu
hein le Bullet ça promet
oui pour ce soir c'est quoi tes
pronostics moi je vois bien une victoire
de La Rochelle je vous le dis très
franchement pour moi c'est La
Rochelle
est-ce que je test tennis manager non on
m'a dit qu'il était complexe du coup
j'ai pas j'ai pas test on m'a dit qu'il
était
difficile et puis bon il y a beaucoup de
tour à d'échec en ce moment je su un peu
quoi
ouais La Rochelle me paraît quand même
plus forte mais
bon il y a un changement de caméra je
sais pas ce qu'ils font c'est un peu
bizarre trop de papier peint tu le
papier peint ouais ais pas trois papier
Pein différent ouais
elle boit la kzac
ouais
terrible et Mathieu van derpool du coup
il fait les
il fait les sprint classique ou
pas de commenter sur chess non pas
spécialement a ça dépend les
compétitions tu des matchs qui
m'intéressent plus que
d'autres gros son équipe team mer
OK
is team Merlier ouais il est très très
bon mais bon après le maillot vert il se
gagne pas forcément sur les il y a pas
beaucoup de sprint non à proprement
parler sur ce Tour de France il y a peu
d'étapes de plat enin peu il y a pas mal
d'étapes
accidentées
arrivé potentiellement massive ouais
mais bon sur les h il y en aura pas h il
y en aura six ou 7 tu as toujours une
étape au long cours tu as toujours une
étape ou deux avec avec des échappé au
long court dans la
plaine mais il y a une une étape avec un
avec potentiellement
des des éventails des cassures des
bordures h plat et quatre accidentés
seulement
donc les deux
premières après il y a des étapes qui
classent en étape de montagne qui sont
pas vraiment des étapes de montagne non
plus hein je trouve
personnellement bon ça va repartir
hein alors en fait ça ça a décalé toutes
les cames attendez on va tout devoir
remettre je voulais voir dans quel sens
ça se mettait ça on peut jamais vraiment
savoir bibi Sant est-ce qu'on la laisse
comme ça non on va lui remettre sa
cam ah tiens une double ou
fan
malheureusement maintenant elle est
cadrée comme ça on voit plus sa
tête je peux pas CAD cadrer mieux que
ça un prochaine P Domingo je voir en
favori non mais là je fais pas assez de
sport en ce moment fa que je m'y
remettre mais si je m'y mettais que je
m'entraîis à fond ouais je pourrais je
pourrais me
défendre mais il faudrait qu'il me
prévienne 2 3 mois à
l'avance pour que j'aille courir t tous
les matins machin et tout que je fasse
du vélo et
cetera mais clairement clairement je
pourrais être pas mal si je
m'entraîne tu fais combien en puzzle
survie euh j'isir fait dans les 60 mais
le truc c'est que je je l'ai fait
vite tu fais du cyclisme non
malheureusement
je pense à un regret de mon père
d'ailleurs qui aurait aimé que je fasse
du cyclisme parce que j'ai des longs
bras et des longues jambes et que je
suis hyper faim du coup j'ai mon père
m'a toujours dit qu' j'avais un physique
de cyclisme mais ouais moi je voulais je
je préférais les sports de j'aurais eu
préférer si j'avais le choix de faire
des sports de contact en
fait j'ai aucune stade vélo mais bon le
truc c'est
que
je mesure combien
1,85 mais j'ai j'ai surtout des longues
des longues jambes et des longs
bras mais non non je fais pas de vélo ni
rien malheureusement mais mon père m' je
dis que j'aurais été un bon cycliste mon
père il a mon père il était bon en
vélo il faisait des sorties de de 130
140 km le weekend donc il envoyait et
mon père il
envoyaiton serait chouette que tu dis
comment tu as
progressé ah ouais mais bon moi j'étais
enfin ça va pas vraiment t'aider cross9
parce que ouais j'étais vraiment très
bon très petit tu vois donc c'est
différent mais là ça fait trop longtemps
que j'ai plus de course à pied que je
fais plus ce genre de choses et vélo
aussi ça fait trop longtemps que j'en
fais plus faudrait que j'en j'en fasse
quelques mois quoi histoire d'être
prêt mais les chaper ils font quoi ils
vont ils font 25 ou 30 bord non c'est
rien en fait après peut-être qu'ils les
font vite mais c'est rien en
soi 25 ou 30 born c'est
rien 32 avec un peu de dénivelé ouais
mais il monte il monte à combien
de il monte à le dénivelé c'est quoi
tant que c'est du 4 5 6 % je passe
tranquille après si c'est 8 9 10 je je
peux
caler ah 8 10 je peux
caler 15 % je peux caler ouais 8 10 15
15 % je pense que je pense que je
cale
après le truc c'est que sur simulateur
tu peux peut-être pas caler
quoi parce que en vrai quand tu montes
moi il m' arrivait de ça m' arrivait de
caler en vélo dansen démonter ou juste
tu peux pas passer en
fait tu peux juste pas passer là faut
faire gaffe
ouais si elle avait bougé la dame il y
aurait eu cavalier prend C7 ou la tour
il aurait pu avoir des c pr C7 tout 7
qui prend C7 et dame prend à
8 sur zwift c'est un peu différent
ok c'est plus dur que sur un vrai vélo
du
coup
is donc du coup ça ça peut ça peut être
chaud parce que sur un vrai vélo 30 km
c'est vraiment
rien
tu peux aller très lentement sans tomber
ouais c'est un avantage
ça tu peux pas vraiment être obligé de
t'arrêter à cause de la pente ouais
c'est c'est le problème quand tu as des
pentes à on sens que ça passe pas pour
le moment quand tu as des pentes à à 14
13 14 % juste tu tu peux tu peux
réellement juste caler en
fait et et du coup ça devient très
difficile pour remonter
ouais c'est bien pour bibissar
encore mifan qui trollle un peu
trop
le 5 E5 je pense ça passe pas vraiment
il y a dame prend F3 enfin c'est pas
forcément mauvais mauvais
mais
bon cavalier D5
ouais B3 c un coup intéressant is mais
elle a voulu rentrer
là-dedans donc
je fais
5 je me demande ce qu'elle veut sur dame
prend D4 en fait ah elle doit vouloir
pion prend tour prend1 dame prend F7 ro
H8 dame F8 et mater du couloir ça assez
malin
ok 6
puis on prend puis on prend t prend
ouais du coup il y a pas tour reprend
parce qu'il y a toujours le truc avec
Dame D7 d dame F7 dame F8
ouais en fait Simp chess c'est un vieux
livre c'est une expression qui est resté
elle menace sur dame prend D4 il a dame
F7 aussi
d'ailleurs je rappelle plus qui c un
grand maître anglais qui avait écrit ce
livre simple chess mais je pense c'est
une expression qui existait déjà
avant qu'est-ce que va jouer bibi Sarah
ici
du coup elle va perdre le truc en aussi
mais je pense dame D5
ouais j'imagine qu'elle va faire je
pensais qu'elle aait faire un dame F5
mais ça c'est bien joué sur G8 elle va
revenir ah elle a dame à 8 aussi ah dame
à 8 tour
tour8 je pense qu'elle va gagner bibi
Sara là normalement elle doit jouer la
pendule parce que wi fan elle met trop
de temps elle trolle
dame g58 va être jouer tempo ici un
genre de coup comme tour tour F2 peut
être pas mal sur sur dame C6
D5 faut pas jouer des coups forcés quand
l'adversaire est très mal au temps ça
l'aide en
fait
ok ro F3 dame ici c'est un peu bête ce
qu'elle a fait bibi
Sarah
terrible et s inventé une life
c'est on discute un peu ce matin avec
Fab comme il était au top 12 et qu'il a
pas joué en réel depuis un
moment
et il disait qu'avec le le recul
maintenant il avait
l'impression lui aussi m qui fait pas
mal de Blitz et de rapide et qui joue
plus sur Internet et en blit en rapide
il disait que finalement lui aussi il
avait l'impression que ça jouait pas
spécialement mieux en longue que qu'en
rapide sur le net enin je ve dire qu'en
rapide comme nous on joue on discute un
peu de ça et du coup il commence à
rejoindre ma
team la team keV qui pense que les les
longues c'est très long pour pas
grand-chose en fait la là par exemple il
me raconta que la partie qu'il a gagné
hier il a juste gagné grâce au Z
not
ouais c'est les noirs qui ont gagné du
coup
ouais un changement de paradigme arrive
ouais ais m'a dit finalement c'est vrai
que ça sert pas à grand-chose de jouer
avec autant de temps sur la pendule
parce que la qualité des partie
c'est jusqu'à vraiment très haut niveau
c'est pas c'est pas
énormissime pour les débutants long
c'est mieux pour apprendre ah jusqu'à un
certain un niveau c'est bien en
fait mais à 700 et tu joues en 15 ou 20
minutes c'est déjà très bien hein pas
besoin de jouer des parties de 6 7h je
pense tu apprendras plus en faisant 10
parties de 20 minutes queun partie de 7h
d'ailleurs on discutait tout à l'heure
ça faisait peut-être vraiment plus plus
trop sens les parties
longues peut-être pour ceux qui calcule
des d'énormes variantes dans le top
c'est nécessaire ouais mais après il y a
aussi la question lendive du coup
peut-être qu'on peut se dire qu'il faut
pas donner 3 heures chacun mais mais
peut-être 3 qu semaines en fait tu es
obligé de donner une limite de temps
donc après il faut trouver une limite de
temps qui lie l'utile à l'agréable en
fait et finalement c'est vrai que quand
tu suis des
parties et qu'elle dure 6 7 he on voit
bien que pour les spectateurs c'est
c'est juste pas tenable donc c'est vrai
que plus tu réfléchis plus tu dis que
les les cadences elle pourrait vraiment
être accéléré ça fait plus autant de
différence qu'avant en
fait et même pour tu vois lui il me
disait pour pour pour le niveau qu'il a
aujourd'hui Fab on en discutait il dis
en fait c'est c'est plus utile d'avoir
autant de temps parce que de toute façon
on fait de la merde en vrai en vrai de
vrai en vrai de vrai on fait des parties
de merde jusqu'à jusqu'à un très haut
niveau donc en soi ça fait pas forcément
sens d'avoir énormément de temps
quoi c'est long et cher pour rien
quoi c'est limite néfaste non c'est pas
néfaste mais Fab il du coup c'est plus
stressant quand tu joues aussi parce que
tu as moins envie de faire une connerie
sur un truc qui dure très longtemps et
au niveau du plaisir de jeu pour lui
maintenant ça devient pareil en fait il
préfère jouer en rapide aussi en fait
mis à part un petit cercle de joueurs
pro qui qui VO qui qui qui représente
2000 personnes dans le monde dans le
monde entier hein pour euh pour tous les
autres donc les les 600 millions
d'autres joueurs puisqu'il y a 600
millions de gens qui jouent aux échecs
c'est mieux les rapide je parle en tant
que spectateur hein tout du moins donc
c'est vrai que ça on favorise 2000
personnes vs 600 millions
quoi ce qui est ce qui est peut-être un
peu dommage en fait après pourquoi pas
hein mais c'est vrai que le le le
rapport de De Personne est quand
même largement en faveur des rapides et
si même même des joueurs pro maintenant
comme Fab et tout commencent au fur et à
mesure à à penser
pareil on favorise les meilleurs B pas
vraiment hein c'est après comme il y a
de l'argent pour même s'il y a pas de
spectateur c'est une chose mais en
vrai en vrai les meilleurs euh ouais du
fait queil y a il y a il y a de l'argent
qui qui qui est là-dedans euh sans trop
de raison ben oui mais sinon à terme à
terme pas vraiment à terme pas
vraiment
là ça doit être bien pour les blancs
parce que il y a il y a une grosse
pression sur la diagonale
he il reste combien de temps du coup
encore 13 minutes de 5 +
1 partie d'échec 5h ouais mais on
pourrait voir quatre ou CIN parties
d'échec en 5h àperto au lieu d'en voir
une on pourrait voir un match en quatre
parties du coup on pourrait voir 4h et
puis bon un match de tennis ça dure
rarement 5h quand même c'est que quand
c'est des beau matchs
les éch c'est c'est S c'est ouais c'est
une étape de pleine là il va y avoir E5
cavalier prend cavalier prend E7 B6 et
F4 du coup B5 elle la fou prend D5 qu
Mme intermédiaire qui sauve encore
heureusement par les achets qui font
parfois des matchs en 30 minutes comme
Nadal tu finir non mais bon faut arrêter
les échecs long ça saoule tout le monde
àperto tu as quasiment personne qui
regarde il faut il faut être réaliste tu
as très peu de spectacle sur une partie
longue d'échec il est nul en 30 minutes
au contraire il s'est juste passé rien
quoi il se passe il se passe vraiment
rien
souvent il se passe vraiment pas
grand-chose
un jur comme Carana sera pas d'accord
avec le raccourcement des cadent ça ce
sera son
problème en tout cas les parties le seul
moment où les échecs ont vraiment été
médiatisés en dehors des des Championnat
du Monde en France et en Europe cétait
avec les trophées himopar et c'était des
parties en rapide cétait 25 plus ça
devait être 25 + 10 ou 30 çaêre des
parties de 50 minutes ou 1 heure et
c'était aussi du rapide
très
clairementin faut donc tranchant le
traditionnalisme et l'effet spectacle B
après moi le traditionnalisme j'ai déjà
dit je suis pas contre mais pour moi le
traditionnalisme c'est jouer sans
pendule faut arrêter de s'inventer des
live et dire que le traditionnalisme
c'est des calances
classiques à mon hble ave c'est pas le
cas parce que la tradition c'est de
jouer sans pendule donc ça ça en fait
c'est cet argument de dire les
traditions c'est de jouer en longue
c'est un argument qui me qui m'agace en
fait c'est c'est vraiment un argument
qui m'agace parce que c'est absolument
pas la tradition des échecs la tradition
les échecs se jouaient au 11e 12e
siècle sans sans pendule et ça s'est
joué sans pendule ule du 11e 12e siècle
jusqu'à la fin du 19e
quoi donc ça m'embête un peu en fait ce
truc de
tradition le match Chion tu veux que
soit rapide oh moi jeis pour qu'il a les
deux cadences en fait moi je suis pour
qu'il a les deux en vrai
je suis pas pour plus longue mais je
suis pour qu' des rapid et des
longu quand on parle tradition on pense
à blanc pas qui fer carp pas au du 11e
siècle ah bah toi ça qui m'embête toujs
avec les traditions c'est de toujours
limiter la tradition à une époque la
tradition ça remonte pas c'est du
sophisme sinon ça remonte pas à l'époque
où ça
t'arrange tradition ça remonte ça ça
remonte à où on veut en fait les échecs
quand même sur l'histoire des échecs il
y a eu beaucoup plus de parties sans
cadence que en cadence
rapide très clairement
hein
ah bah très clairement parce qu'après
sinon on va toujours te prendre la
tradition à l'année où on veut
quoi la pu en ple milieu de la
tradition c'est un peu de la mauvaise
foi j' que c'est sujectif bah pour moi
c'est de la mauvaise foi les gens qui te
disent que la tradition ENF moi c'est
c'est je vois le chos contraire àperto
c'est la tradition de quand tu étais toi
enfant mais c'est pas la vraie
tradition
ah ça ça s'appelle une dam il fallait
prendre du pion
dommage
donc cavalier C3 bon ça repart ouais bon
Wian qui est plus forte hein il reste
encore beaucoup de parties c'est
peut-être la dernière de cette
cadence après moi je pense qu'il
pourrait y avoir les deux cadences et
puis on verrait bien c'est celle qui
plaît le plus aux gens en fait hein et
celle que les que les gens les les
cadences qui sont le plus suivis et puis
on voilà ce serait tu pourrais faire un
TRT de grand mare pour les rapides aussi
et puis
euh et tu pourrais faire quoabiter les
deux il y aurait pas de souci en
fait mais avant c'était mieux après zic
c'est vrai aussi
après la FIDE elle est forcément de ton
côté àperto ouais elle aime pas le
changement la
Fed ça c'est sûr la FIDE elle veut que
rien ne change et que ça reste pareil
mais après comme je disais un tant qu'il
y a des des gens qui veulent envoyer des
milli pour pour des compétitions qui
sont regardées par 3000 personnes ça
continuera à marcher en fait il y a pas
de on a déjà parlé la dernière fois mais
il y a pas de de réalité économique
derrière en fait c'est juste des gens
qui qui envoient de l'argent comme ça
quoi pourquoi pas hein mais je veux dire
par là que ça c'est que comme il y a pas
d'obligation de résultats et de et de
réalité économique
derrière ça peut continuer comme ça
longtemps hein après s'il y avait une
vraie réalité économique et que c'était
et et que ça marchait avec dans dans
dans un monde plus ou
moins normal ça ça mourrait par soi-même
en
fait si les gens sont contents en l'état
actuel très bien mais c'est quand même
triste le haut niveau bah en fait c'est
pas les gens qui sont content c'est
quelques milliardaires en fait qui
financ le
truc c'est quelques milliardaires qui
sont contents
de j'emploie le mot milliardaire mais
les mecs on sont peut-être juste très
très riches hein ça veut pas le mot
milliard ici et est pas
employé peut-être à à à bon ant mais
c'est c'est quelques personnes très très
riches qui sont contentes en
fait
donc je pense qu'il avoir des pr C5 fou
pran et tour D1 normalement pour jouer
le pion
isolé les échecs au j serait absolument
excellent après c'est pas un sport donc
ce serait spécial si les Jeux Olympiques
acceptent les échecs pourquoi pas le
bridge après pourquoi pas
fortnite l'idée des Jeux Olympiques
c'est quand même des des des des sports
où il faut au moins de la agilité
physique quoi moi ça me paraît complexe
les échecs aux Jeux
Olympiques c'est c'est c'est
pas on est pas un sport à proprement
dire physique on est un sport
intellectuel et il y a d'ailleurs he ce
qu'on appelle les mind games ça existe
c'est des genres de jeux olympiques des
des jeux d'esprit et notre place c'est
plutôt plutôt dans ce dans ce registre
làin
si les milliardaires arrêtent de
financer les tournois à long et que la
fil ne se bougeit pas un peu ah ouais
non s'il y avait plus les milliardaires
et les sociétés russes pour financer les
les les tournois clairement ça
changerait par obligation en fait si les
échecs devaient être médiatisés pour
avoir de l'argent de de revenus
publicitaire comme absolument tous les
autres sports quasiment obligatoirement
on passerait au cadence rapide en fait
il y aurait juste pas de choix et ça
passerait forcément par par du rapide
mais mais mais tant que tant tant que tu
as de l'argent qui tombe un peu comme ça
euh ça ça bougera pas
et comme je l'avais déjà dit je trouve
ça aussi assez logique hein
finalement et je trouve ça assez logique
au final
donc tu peux commenter écoute je suis là
pour commenter le speed chess comme je
disais le Top 12 ça m'intéresse pas
beaucoup plus infinet euh du coup euh
moi vraiment dans le sport en général
sorti des des tournois
d'élite je suis rarement vraiment
vraiment vraiment hypé
hein pour moi c'est surtout le sport de
haut niveau qui se commente le reste ça
se joue hein c'est c'est très sympa de
enfin moi j'adore j'adore jouer au
tennis ou quoi mais après ça ça se vit
plus
euh ça ça se vit plus pour moi le sport
quand c'est quand c'est pas du top
niveau
euh que que de se commenter quoi tu
imaginerais pas avoir les interclubs de
tennis à la télé par
exemple il y a qui au top 12 ben il y a
pas mal de monde mais en fait ça
rapporte pas vraiment enfin c'est pas un
titre prestigieux ou quoi en fait il a
il y a rien à gagner en soi enfin il y a
rien à gagner il y a le Top 12 à gagner
mais c'est pas un titre en soi
quoi
infin
infin c'est pas un
titre en c'est bien pour pour l'équipe
pour la ville qu'il gagne mais bon enfin
c'est
pas c'est pas quelque chose d'incroyable
on va dire ça comme
ça ça se mtir enfant les gandat non je
sais pas ça ça sert
à ça sert à avoir des des tournois mais
c'est
pas la Ligue 1 il a rien à gagner non
mais c'est un sport individuel les
échecs c'est pas un sport collectif
c'est complètement
différent le Top 12 c'est un championnat
de France par
équipe donc c'est c'est c'est pas mal
c'est tant mieux pour les équipes qui
jouent les joueurs qui jouent he c'est
pas ça mais en
soi les échecs c'est quand même un sport
individuel au-delà de au-delà de tout
quoi le Top 12 ça fait vivre les PR
ouais c'est ça en fait c'est en vrai en
vrai c'est exactement ça frch ça permet
de d'avoir plus plus facilement des
subventions des des des mairies pour
pour pouvoir payer payer les joueurs et
leur faire gagner un peu d'argent quoi
en vrai c'est ça surtout surtout qu'au
échecs en plus tu as la chance de
pouvoir jouer dans 5 si clubs différents
en Europe je crois que tu peux même
monter jusqu'à 8 ne9 clubs si tu te
débrouilles bien donc là encore hein ça
ça baisse évidemment l'intérêt sportif
du délire puisque tu peux jouer dans
absolument autant de clubs que tu le
souhaites donc il y a même pas vraiment
de de de fierté du club ou quoi c'est
c'est vraiment mais mais c'est vrai que
ça permet au aux joueurs pro euh bah
voilà d'être d'être payé de gagner un
peu d'argent c'est
cool
mais sportivement c'est
pas c'est pas la panacée
quoi fa il était pas bien il son bien
sorti ouais ça
va
j aussi c'est indivel en équipe ça a une
autre dimension euh ouais mais déjà
c'est c'est différent et en plus quand
tu regardes les les les sports comme ça
par équipe tu regardes plus les équipes
nationales comme la coupe DESV au
tennis c'est à partir de quel él compète
que tu as commencé à bloquer c'est dur à
dire parce que moi j'ai eu des des des
petits problèmes de santé quand j'avais
15 16 ans donc j'ai bloqué mais en fait
je bloquis pas forcément à cause de mes
compétences aux
échecs donc c'est difficile à dire mais
je pense j'aurais bloquer vers 24 50 25
en
fait sans être sûr d'avoir pu monter
plus
haut
donc il y a moins de de filles
professionnelles que de
garçons cette fois erreur après il faut
aussi
dire que les compétitions garçons sont
en réalité des compétition mixte donc
les filles pourraient très bien y
participer en réalité et il y a aussi
beaucoup moins de filles qui jouent aux
échecs du coup c'est pour ça qu'elles
sont moins fortes en en garçon du coup
proportionnellement je sais pas s'il y a
plus de femmes ou d'hommes si on parle
en
proportion pourquoi je vais plus en
tournoi parce que ça m'intéresse plus
là normalement le pion D6 il est
vraiment fort faire F7 et sur tour t
prend2 faut essayer de garder la tour
ici sur la deuxè je pense c'est bien
joué mais quand il y a tour à 2 elle
pourra pas monter ouais tour à 2 est
chiant ça
tour7our des5
D8 et maintenant il y a le tour à 2 tour
qui est pén faire
tour2 ouais ça va faire
perpétuel marrance ce
perpète et donc ça va finir à
42 bon je je je reviens je vais je vais
faire une pause j'ai un petit truc à
faire
j'arrive
bon je suis de retour ouais ça remarche
j'avais coupé le micro aussi
ouais allez à toute l'ombre de kè ouais
donc voilà
je discutais de quoi je parlais ouais je
parlais de compétition par équipe bah
moi je trouve pas ça ouais très
passionnant euh à titre personnel
hein je trouve pas ça très passionnant à
titre
personnel mais euh mais après euh après
chacun chacun sa vision des choses hein
euh pourquoi pas
mais ouais pour moi is les compétitions
individuelles comme dans tous les sports
individuels sont pre et les compétitions
par
équipe sont plus serait à mon avis plus
fait pour des joueurs amateurs un peu
bah comme je dis moi jouer au tennis en
fait je vois c'est hyper cool quand
amateur de faire les les les interclubs
ça c'est marrant se permet d'aller avec
des potes ou quoi mais mais c'est pas
fait pour faire jouer Nadal contre
Djokovic dans toutes les ligues du monde
et dans tous les pays surtout le le le
le fait qu'aux échecs comme je disais on
puisse jouer dans plusieurs clubs ça
dévalue encore plus le le côté spectacle
des
compétition parce que les les joueurs
qui vont jouer dans des équipes en
France ils vont rejouer dans les mêmes
équipes en Espagne ils vont refaire les
mêmes championnats ils vont rejouer
ensemble je trouve je trouve ça moi
très très étrange d'un point de vue
public c'est enfin si tu joues en club
tu joues dans un club tu joues pas dans
40 clubs
quoi
c'est n'importe quoi comme règle B ouais
pour moi par enfin c'est comme si tu
regardes un match je sais pas tu as le
PSG tu as Mbappé Mbappé le weekend
d'après il joue avec le Real 3 semaine
après il va jouer avec avec Manchester
United la 4è semaine il joue avec le
Bayern bon enfin ok bon bah du coup en
quand tu es public si tu as ton équipe
tu as tes joueurs qui jouent dans ton
club depuis longtemps et tout c'est ça
ça mett TR plus il y aurais peut-être
plus
d'intérêt mais là en fait après quand il
les clubs se qualifient en Coupe
d'Europe tu peux avoir tes joueurs qui
jouent contre ta propre équipe parce que
il jouaiit dans une autre équipe
qualifiée dans une autre ligue donc en
fait partant de là enfin pour moi ça ça
tue en déjà qu'il y a pas vraiment
d'intérêt sportif comme je disais à à
mes yeux ça tue complètement l'intérêt
sportif du délire
quoi de mon point de vue
de mon point de vue ça ça ça dévalue le
truc après on participera à la proess
League si ça se joue parce que c'est
marrant et parce qu'on le fait avec la
commue on le fait entre nous mais mais
voilà c'est parce qu'on aura une équipe
et qu'on suivra notre équipe quoi et en
proess League tu peux pas jouer pour 40
clubs en fait tu as une compétition sur
Internet c'est la PR chest League tu
joues pour ton club tu joues toute la
saison tu changes pas de enfin tu joues
pas dans 40 clubs en même temps
quoi donc ça c'est mon côté spectateur
après pour les joueurs comme je disais
c'est très bien parce que ça ça permet
de dans dans des compétitions par équipe
il y a beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent
euh et ça c'est
bien et ça ça c'est bien parce que c'est
vrai quand tu quand tu cumules toutes
les toutes les ligues si pour un joueur
aux alentours de 25 50 26 s'il joue dans
toutes les ligue ça lui fait quasiment
un salaire annuel peut-être pas mais
suivant comment il se débrouille il peut
il peut avoir beaucoup de revenus je
rappelle Vlad qui me disait que pour sa
dernière année en fait la dernière année
où il a joué il était 2650 ce qui lui
rapportait le plus d'argent et de loin
c'était les
ligues j top 10 son joue dans un club
alors il jouent dans des clubs en
Allemagne souvent parce que c'est là
qu's ont vraiment le plus d'argent ils
sont prêts à payer je pense plusieurs
milliers d'euros pour une partie donc
c'est pour ça que j'ai il y a vraiment
des moyens et ça c'est
bien et ça c'est
bien mais là paremple je pense Maxime
joue avec un club il doit jouer avec
anère carwana et tout il rejoue ensemble
en en Allemagne Maxime il joue dans
l'équipe on avait regardé des parties de
Bundesliga qui est en réalité la Ligue
la plus sympa parce que c'est là qu'il y
a les plus forts joueurs pour la peine
ouais les olympies apriss et c'est cool
c'est cool parce que c'est par c'est par
équipe et Jul je suis ok c'est étrange m
Cup mais le club Top 12 c'est cool on
peut suiv un peu les joueurs que tu nous
as fait connaître ouais mais bon il joue
pour rien en fait peut-être qu'il gagne
ou qui perde ça change rien c'est ça le
problème c'est pas c'est c'est pas une
compétition qui te ramène vraiment
quelque chose quoi et puis bon ça joue
pas contre du top
mondial non la Ligue la plus sympa c'est
la Ligue allemande qui qui comme je vous
le disais est de loin la Ligue la plus
euh la plus
forte B ils ont une Gal équipe ouais
parce qu'ils jeent avec graen que du
coup en fait ils ont deux clubs
bigeviller en gros ils ont un club en en
France bigevillire et ils ont l'autre
club greenco je sais plus quelle ville
c'est c'est en Allemagne et du coup ils
ont plus ou moins les mêmes joueurs dans
les deux
clubs
Badon Badon ou ça doit être Badon Badon
ouais ah quoi que
ouais après voir Mazo liby et tout c'est
sympa mais après quand tu vois la partie
de Mazo hier par exemple même celle de
liby c'est
pas comme disait la partie d'hier je
fais la même en blitz quoi la partie de
Mazo il me disait c'est la même dans les
titles Tuesday quoi
pas je sais pas c'est pas un titre perso
VO c'est pas une compète qui
me que je trouve que je trouve
passionnante peut-être en Coupe d'Europe
je serais un peu plus quoi que on avait
su la Coupe d'Europe ensemble c'était
pas non plus ultra passionnant
non c'est plus intéressant de suivre un
Fab ou quoi sur des touris comme
Gibraltar avec le top mondial et tout ça
c'est plus cool parce que tu peux gagner
un gros tournoi quoi c'est un
majeur
donc bon après je vous dis ça mais d'un
autre côté j'adore j'adore suivre enfin
je suis de temps en temps la ProD2 mais
bon c'est un sport collectif c'est
différent pr de serait l'équivalent de
parti à 2650 quoi si on prenait un sport
individuel donc ouais c'est vrai que ça
reste quand même pas
mal et le prochain un gros tournoi pour
Maxime ce sera
Zagreb mais qui est pas forcément ultra
important parce que ça arrive juste
avant la Coupe du Monde qui sera là
vraiment le tournoi
important bon çachange en E4 il reste
combien de temps de match 42 minutes ok
42 minutes pour ça et encore on a 25
minutes après B on va attendre petit à
petit et après on a le deuxième match je
me rappelle plus des joueuses je vais
regarder plus
tard non mais après tu vois si le Top 12
ils avaient peut-être un système en
coupe sur 3 4 jours ça pourrait se
regarder là c'est long aussi bon je pas
on est on s'est longtemps égaré sur ce
sujet mais c'est vrai que en plus ça du
mon jours c'est long quoi et sans format
championnat il y a pas de play-off à la
fin enfin c'est tu vois c'est une phase
play-off à la fin genre demi-finale
finale peut-être la fin ce serait cool à
regarder est-ce qu'on va avir max sur la
chaîne dans les semaines à venir et non
trop pris par les tournois à la maxime
Sarka contre michuko voilà on gardera ça
après
terrible le prer le second de la Coupe
du Monde ouais les deux finalistes sont
qualifiés pour les candidats c'est
exactement ça le Marocain du coup en
fait c'est marrant C Coupe du monde mais
en fait la finale n'a pas grand intérêt
mais les demi-finales sont
exceptionneles ça qui est marrant en
fait c'est que la la vraie finale de la
Coupe du monde sont les deux
demi-finales qui qui évidemment un
intérêt immense puisque ça joue la Calif
quoi c'est les deux vraies finales en
fait tu as deux tournois en vrai des en
Coupe du Monde tu as deux tournois tu as
un tableau un tableau bas et l'objectif
c'est d'arriver en finale c'est pas
vraiment de gagner et d'ailleurs ils ont
fait un truc bien cette année c'est
qu'avant la finale elle était en quatre
parties et comme les joueurs en avaient
marre de jouer qu'à chaque fois il
turbot troll les quatre parties parce
que bah voilà c'est le le le truc était
fait ils ont laissé la finale en deux
parties ils ont laissé la finale en deux
parties et et et du coup tu auras pas
cette finale qui avant était un peu
longue à la fin et là du coup elle sera
quand même sympa à suivre puisque les
joueurs peuvent peut-être jouer sur deux
parties essayer de se battre et au pire
ça fait tout de suite despartages donc
c'est assez cool mais mais oui non sympa
cette Coupe du monde avec avec ouais
comme je disais donc les demi-finales
les les les deux matchs enfin les les
deux matchs les plus intéressant et tu
as tu as deux finales à suivre en même
temps c'est très sympa et ça c'est
vraiment un beau tournoi tu vois la
Coupe du Monde c'est un tournoi que
j'aime réellement c'est un de mes
tournoi préférés les candidats la Coupe
du Monde et les Grands Prix feed c'est
pour moi les les les les meilleurs
tournois bah il y a pas de mystère hein
ce sont les seuls tournois en jeu toute
la saison et tout de suite et les
Olympiades j'aime bien aussi tiens tu
vois comment on parlerit des trucs par
équipe
ah la bibisara qui prend cher une
nouvelle fois complètement terminado
cette
position mais ça ce sont vraiment pour
moi les les les les compétitions
phare aprs c'est logique tout le reste
c'est que du match amical en fait c'est
il y a pas de c'est
normal Coupe du Monde ah ouais Coupe du
Monde de rapidebl c'est top aussi ouais
mais tu vois en fait je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec toi nabris moi toutes les
compétitions qui me plaisent en fait
c'est les compétitions où il y a quelque
chose derrière parce que finalement le
reste je vois pas la différence entre
une Arena Kings ou ou un title Tuesday
ou ces tournois là bon à part que c'est
c'est un peu un peu mieux surveillé ou
quoi mais sinon en terme d'enjeu enin
title Tuesday est plus fort en
vrai mais mais ouais ouais non du coup
pour moi le le circuit professionnel
j'ai j'ai besoin pour pour vibrer que
que ça joue pour quelque chose Zagreb en
rapide ouais on va suivre mais c'est pas
voilà c'est quand même largement en
dessous là s field Cup c'est un event
que j'aime bien
après après la S Cup c'est un TR que
j'aime bien généralement il y a des
belles parties à la S fi Cup c'est en
fait je pense j'ai une théorie l'autre
jour alors je sais pas si elle est vraie
ou fausse mais je me suis dit c'est vrai
que ils font moins de turbo nul et tout
parce que le le sponsor sink field des
de tous ces tournois de tout le circuit
du Grand chest tour le sponsor principal
il vient regarder toutes les parties en
fait il passe 4 5 he il paraît dans la
salle de jeu pour suivre les parties de
la S field Cup et je pense que les gars
vu l'argent que le mec met
sans retour sur investissement ils
doivent pas trop avoir envie de turbo
nul en une demi-heure je pense qu'ils
sentent que devant le gars lui-même tu
peux pas trop le faire quoi
et c'est vrai que cette pickup il y a
souvent des belles parties et tu sens
qu'il y a un enjeu plus
important mais donc oui pour moi le
le ce tournoi là est le le est le plus
sympa
de de tous les de tous les grandes
chaises tour pour moi c'est le le plus
sympa c'est la la SIG que F
Cup et la la finale du Grand chaest Tour
aussi était sympa les phases finales de
la Grand cha tour du Grand chaest Tour
après en 2019 elles étaient très mal
placées dans le calendrier parce
qu'elles étaient juste avant le tournoi
décisif des grands prefed mais sinon
c'est assez sympa
aussi
ouis ils prennent des leçons de Rex et
rendy le dernier jour non mais c'est une
compète sympa tu vois pour parler des
compètes que j'aime
bien j'ai trouvé le Paris grand chest
tour très décevant perso mais peut-être
parce que j'attendais plus Bucharest
était clairement décevant aussi je suis
assez inquiet pour le grand chessour
Zagreb qu'on a un peu le droit à à à du
décevant aussi mais après je suis assez
confiant pour la Coupe du monde et pour
pour pour la SN field Cup et ensuite
pour le le tournoi de l' of man aussi d'
va être super tiens j'ai oublié un
tournoi dans la saison qui est aussi
excellent c'est l'
ofman le niveau était vraiment pas ouf
j'ai trouvé au grand sur Paris après
comme disait Vlad hier il a dit à
plusieurs reprises faut dire qu'il joue
tellement bien sur Internet maintenant
il smoule que peut-être qu'on a perdu
l'habitude du niveau hors internet aussi
hein c'est vrai que ça joue dur he sur
internet il joue vraiment bien les
gars donc c'est vrai que Paris euh le le
niveau de jeu à Paris après avoir suivi
les joutes Internet peut peut paraître
faible ce que disait Vlad
hier on pouvait avoir à cause de ça un
genre de biais quoi
cognitif alors que de base il jouaient
très mal sur Internet puis après ils
sont
habitués d'ailleurs pour toi KF c'est
justifié d' des places au candidat pour
un open ah moi je j'en mettrai je
mettrai plus de de places je les mettrai
toutes sur des tournois de type open
parce que les candidats c'est c'est
quand même un tournoi auquel tout le
monde peut
participer tu peux devenir champion du
monde donc c'est c'est normal que tout
le monde puisse se qualifier après ce
que je ferais dans l'idéal c'est que je
feraai un peu comme il faisait avant je
mettrai 16 joueurs trouver un système en
mettant 16 joueurs et et donner quelques
places au ho en fait parce que ça c'est
c'est une obligation et et plus de place
après dans les trucs ouverts cependant
euh il y a quand même la Coupe du Monde
qui est ouverte et le et l' love Man et
après il y a les Grands Prix sur
Sélection donc ce qu' a fait la feed
c'est quand même assez bien en fait je
dois dire que j'ai été très critique de
la Fed pendant pendant un certain temps
mais je dois reconnaître que ce qu'ils
font depuis plusieurs années me me
paraît
intéressant je je trouve qu'ils ont
trouvé une bonne balance et que c'est
beaucoup plus réfléchi qu'avant et qu'il
font quelques bons trucs
ouais ça jouit vraiment très très bien
sur Internet oua il smou donc c'est vrai
que le retour sur éque réel voilà et
puis c'est plus dur de jouer en en réel
hein tout simplement pour certains pas
pour tous pour certains ça change rien
pour d'autres peut-être que ça crée des
petites
différences
après je vais regarder je vais dire au
revoir à VAD V là qui est en train de
retourner à Moscou il avait laissé ses
bagages chez lui quand il part je vais
aller je vais aller
saluerevir
arz à partir on a oublié un petit truc
donc je regarde le match se continue
désolé les gars g un petit truc
ouais qu'est-ce que ça donne ça doit
être nul ce truccl bon on n pas raté
grand-chose du
coup on va dire au revoir à Vlad aussi
il on a égaré un truc en fait tous les
deux mais je vois pas où
c'est mais c'est pas très
grave c'est pas très grave bon du coup
il y a eu nul oua dans la petite
finale le respect ouais non non c'est
pas le passeport c'est un un souvenir un
cadeau qui qui voulait ramener mais on
sa plus on l'a mis dans son
bagage mais c'est pas c'est pas quelque
chose
de c'est pas dans le Range de grave quoi
c'est dans le Range de pas
grave c'est pas dans le Range passeport
papier important ou quoi ni dans le
Range objet de grande valeur donc ça
va c'est pas
gravissime je vais dire au revoir à Vlad
du
coup par maintenant je dire au revoir et
je
revienséussi
àou
g bon les gars je suis de retour
ouais je disais au revoir à Vlad en fait
il cherchait le truc le truc il a pas
trouvé j'étais allé lui dire au revoir
du coup
puisqu'il est rentré chez lui
ouais é au top
hier
bon on en est où on en est à
63 ceux qui ont raté vladiier vous avez
raté quelque chose
surtout ceux qui sont là maintenant et
qui ont raté vladier je dirais cel ils
sont vraiment ouf il y a un deuxième
match en plus ah ouis ouais juste
derrière aujourd'hui c'est de matchs à
6h de match là d'affilé on en quoi on
est à 2h de match ça ça avance ça avance
petit à petit c'est un peu comme une
étape du Tour de France quoi on
s'approche non raté vladiier c'est
terrible surtout il smou être ici
maintenant et rater vladier c'est
terrible hier c'était vraiment marrant
d'ailleurs vous avez vu le clip
ouais il y a encore 4h mais bon après il
y a encore la semaine prochaine encore
un quart de finale deux demi-finales et
une finale et la finale en plus le
format il est plus long pour être bien
sûr bon courage avance merci lat
chess
ah mais les autres matchs ouais il y
aura du Tour de France en même temps
quand même
oh le match de lundi prochain il y aura
Tour de France en même temps mais c'est
une étape de plaine oh ça aurait été
beau d'avoir une étape de montagne en
même
temps
j'espère que le CH est conséquent non en
vrai pas du tout
hein en vrai pas du
tout du
coup mardi le Tour de France pare
pilepoil sous ma fenêtre truc de dingue
ah moi c'est jamais arrivé ça il passe
pas à CAN mais une fois j'ai vu le
parinis il va prendre et là il va y
avoir quoi tour D7 tour
D1 ah mais c'est terrible d'avoir raté
Vlad
hier
marrant les pion
triplet espère qu'est-ce fait que cette
compète est pas ouf à commenter plein de
choses mal placé dans le calendrier en
premier en premier lieu des buulon pas
très intéressante
sportivement mais surtout mal placé dans
le
calendrier
surtout très mal placé dans le
calendrier beaucoup de matchs long tu
vois comme là qui dure et et
voilà mais on va dire c'est ouais c'est
surtout son placement dans le calendrier
avec le le grand chest tour avant le
grand chest tour après la Coupe du Monde
qui arrive et là tu as ce tournoi qui
est un peu qui est un peu calé qui qui
dure très longtemps en plus hein qui
dure qui dure au final 4 semaines avec
des matchs très très long ça enlève
quelque chose la qualité de jeu ah la
qualité de jeu est pas présente non plus
Z
Bulon donc ça fait ça ça fait beaucoup
d'éléments et pas d'en jeu surtout donc
pas d'en jeu
sportif disons que le l'événement aurait
bien été placé
entre octobre novembre dernier et
février mars en fait des Jes de second
plan non c'est des joueus de du top
niveau globalement mais
euh mais mal placé il va y avoir la
Coupe du Monde Féminine les les
candidats les le dernier Grand Prix
féminin là qui vient de se terminer les
compétitions filles en a eu beaucoup et
globalement le niveau féminin est plus
faible que le niveau mixte donc c'est
comme le speedchess junior qui va
arriver c'est moins intéressant de
suivre les juniors ou les filles que que
les
mixtes en soi bah d'ailleurs ça se voit
hier on a vu des mats en un raté là
aussi on voit une partie qui tourne
complètement de manière très bizarre les
Blancs étaient gagnants là ils sont
complètement foutus c'est d'ailleurs les
noirs qui vont gagner
ici ça se voit en fait c'est passer de
gagnant à perdant en trois
coups on aura été hpé par la présence de
DD ouais bah il y aurait eu DD qui jouit
ça aurait été
différent mais bon comme je disais c'est
surtout le placement dans la saison qui
est
mauvais c'est surtout le placement qui
est mauvais parce que c'est vrai que
mettre mettre ses compétitions sur
Internet au beau milieu de la reprise
des vraies compétitions c'est c'est très
étrange en
fait on n pas de de français ce niveaulà
non plus vraiment on en a eu mais pas en
ce
moment bien non on est allé se coucher
direct
hieran qu'elle arrê les compétion fin
qu'elle ne ferait plus que du mix ouais
mais ça c'est pas comme je te dis c'est
pas vraiment une compétition en fait
c'est pour ça qu'elle joue c'est un truc
comme ça semi-amical
quoi l'avantage c'est qu'on peut
discuter tranquille ah bah oui voilà
juste on discute un peu longtemps à mon
goût mais on peut discuter
ouais ah ouais le timing est important
dans la vie
hein
le timing est important tu mets la même
compète en février au moment où il y a
pas de compétition elle est intéressante
mais bon faudrait qu'elle soit moins
moins longue aussi he parce queà chaque
fois c'est match de 3h3 et ils jouent
tous un moment séparé et il y a enfin
bon c'est c'est c'est pas très bien
foutu il devrait jouer les elle devrait
jouer sur une semaine la compétition et
les matchs devrai jouer plus ou moins en
même temps comme fait
le le champion sour de Magnus Carlsen
d'ailleurs ça ils ont bien compris ils
ont bien raison de le faire ils jouent
pas les quarts tous les quarts de finale
à des moments décalés en fait ils joue
les quatre quarts de finale en même
temps et chacun prend un peu le match
qu'il a envie
quoi et chacun prend un peu le match
qu'il a
envie ciao
philosophe là çarai que le fait de jouer
tous les matchs de manière décalé ça ça
rend le tournoi très très long dans le
temps
du coup c'est c'est c'est pour moi
clairement un défaut
aussi les exhibitions doivent rester des
exhibitions et les tournois entre
guillemets qui joue pour la saison
mondiale doivent rester des T qui joue
pour la saison mondiale et une
exhibition ça doit rester quelque chose
de fun qui se prend pas trop au sérieux
quoi ça c'est vrai que c'est dans les
point positif du du Champions Tour le le
fait
que que ça se joue en même temps parce
que si le Champions Tour bon déjà c'est
comp sur Internet une semaine on a vite
marre mais si ça se jouait pendant 3 qu
semaines chaque chaque tournoi on en
pourrait plus quoi déjà on en peut plus
mais
euh mais c'est vrai que c'est un point
très
positif
y a-t-il aussi long chez les hommes ou
en mixte bah mis à part ces t sur
Internet de type speedchest non non ils
en généralement en fait tu tu tu fais
pas un truc qui soit si long dans le
temps quoi en fait ça en vrai ça je
trouve que ça fait aucun sens mais
bon après c'est pour faire plus
d'audience pour avoir plus de temps vu
plus de passer plus de pub et cetera
mais
bon je trouve que ça nuit à la
compétition que les demi-finales et que
la finale soi une manière séparée
pourquoi pas mais
là
mais là c'est vrai que c'est un peu
étrange comme comme
choix encore que bon ils ont quand même
mis les deux matchs d'affile et ça c'est
vrai que c'est quand même un du mieux
le speed classique et le speedess junior
ouis c'est terrible
je pense ça va faire tour D1 cavalier F4
elle va essayer
de de
bloquer
terrible je pensais qu'elle mettrait le
fou en D4 pour ESS mais bon raison pour
le mettre en
C5
j'arrive pas à comprendre comment il y a
4100 personnes sur chcom bah en fait le
truc c'est que chesscom comme ils sont
host sur la chaîne sur la
page principale de de chesscom quand tu
l'ouvres il y a automatiquement 4000
personnes donc en réalité ça veut dire
qu'organiquement il y a 400 500
personnes qui regardent c'est pour ça
que souvent tu vois des des streams tu
as tout un streamur
américains qui sont qui sont aux
alentours de 8 9000 vues en réalité il y
a 4 5000 person
et du coup là faut te dire que en
réalité il y a 600 700 personnes qui
regardent genre max en
fait c'est c'est l'unique raison pour
laquelle ils ont autant de monde qui
suit il y en a pas d'autre
pour ce match non
a non elle s'en fout je pense qu'elle
s'en
fout ah merci pour l'exation d'un coup
ça fait sens ouais ouais c'est ça en
fait c'est juste un truc qu'il faut
savoir euh sur euh sur le sur
l'international c'est que il y a
tellement de monde qui passe et les gens
sont comptabilisés pendant pendant
quelques secondes et et euh c'est pour
ça que des fois tu as des streamers
américains que tu penses enfin
anglophone un peu non mais qui ont 3
4000 personnes c'est juste parce que
c'est chesscom qui les met en
avant
donc non en réalité il y a pas grand
monde qui regarde même en anglais on
doit être à peu près autant en organique
on ils doivent être à peine plus que
nous en surhpant
l'événement et non le speitch junior
c'était le peut-être le moins
intéressant l'an dernier parce qu'il y
avait trop d'écart de niveau et il y
avait beaucoup beaucoup de matchs qui
étai des purges et c'est trop long aussi
donc non c'était pas pas spécialement
intéressant non
plus
c'est le speedchass adulte qui est le
intéressant donc cavalier F1 mais bibi
Sarah ouais elle peut faire la surprise
fan elle m'a pas l'air d'être en super
forme l'année dernière elle avait
quasiment perdu au premier tour l'an
dernier c'était des Grands Prix le
stchess féminin
elle perdait systématiquement au premier
ou deuxème
tour et on sent que IFAN elle est pas
méga plus méga concerné c'est
l'impression que ça la saoule un
peu tardant il y a quelques tournois que
ouais je devais commenter ouais ça
changera peut-être dans la à l'avenir
mais on va dire qu'avant j'avais pas
trop le choix que d'accepter mais mais
mais ouais ça changera peut-être à
l'avenir
va faire fou
B1 mais en vrai tu feris le même match
avec un format le match il dure une
heure ou quoi ça pourrait être cool là
c'est juste que ça dure ça dure beaucoup
trop longtemps il y a beaucoup trop de
parties par rapport à à l'enjeu minime
qu'il y a quoi c'est
tout c'est tout et du coup ça crée un un
souci en plus tous jouent en bullette à
la fin ce qui est la cadence la moins
intéressante au
final en tout cas fan qui a bien troll
la troll plein de positions gagnantes là
elle continue à réfléchir si elle
continue comme ça elle va perdre mais ça
ça se voit vraiment que ça la
saoule c'est pas mal de faireevenenir le
F en B1 oh bah tu repartiras plus tard
hein pas grave mais surtout faut jouer
plus
vite
pour les seuls spech qui é intéressant
c'est ce que tu as présenté à de don du
dynamisme bah ouais mais c'est parce que
c'est les beaux match Jul m c'est tombé
sur les beaux matchs aussi les matchs
les matchs qui étaient pas top quand je
les a commenté avec Fab ou avec Mazo ou
avec Baky ou
quoi ça vient des affiches c'est sûr que
quand tuas un mvl Carlsen ou on a
commenté quoi on a commenté mvl Carlsen
on a commenté du Ikaru Carlsen on a
commenté du mvl Ikaru on a commenté du
Carlsen artéief enfin tout ça c'est des
matchs qui te c'est différent quand même
c'est pas la même chose et en plus
c'était des matchs qui étaient assez
serré tu es hypé quand
même ça joue bien
quoi c'est pas la même ce que j'ai
commenté seul aussi quand c'était des
belles affiches était très cool mais
c'est différent tu vois tu as du firouja
fait CF enfin il y il y a eu
il y a eu des très beau matchs je peux
t'en citer quelquesuns du mvl gritou il
y a eu du sonaka enfin ouais ok c'est
cool c'est cool c'est
cool il y a il y a eu quelques quelques
très beau match
effectivement
après nous aussi quand on avait fait la
Cup avec les filles CIT assez sympa mais
on avait un format qui était plus plus
dynamique ça y fait
beaucoup pouroir de belles affiches il
faut juste du bon jeu B parce que
généralement le champion du monde quand
tu as quand tu as des joueurs du Top 10
mondial ça joue généralement
mieux donc les belles affiches ont
souvent les meilleurs les meilleurs
joueurs je serais capable de les battre
Parah contre bibi Sara ouais je mène 2
et demi 1 demi par
exemple et mon ho max doit être
supérieur de 100 ou 150 points sur
chesscom
donc dans ce format là oui en longue
elle me battrait en classique mais dans
ce format là je serais favori
ouais mais ça fait si si soifan qui je
sais pas elle joue pas enfin comment
direa on joue on sent qu'elle joue mieux
mais elle prend trop de temps et elle
trolle du coup
elle s'effondre
elle
s'effondre c'est les
fondrada elle va perdre je pense au
final comme je le disais en début de
match elle trollle trop à la pendule il
reste combien de temps là dans dans
cette cadence il doit plus rester
grand-chose plus que 8 minutes tien
c'est peut-être l'avant-dernière partie
et on va passer sur le
Blitz mais ouais mais
fan ça se voit dans le langage pour elle
ça se sent que ça qu'elle est
saouleré
vraiment alors que Bibi Sara elle est
très
déterminée prends C7 alors là
malheureusement c'est au noir de jouer
elle va sûrement faire un cavalier à 6
je
pense et récupérer à
deux al tellement s'en fout ouais ça ça
se voit
clairement très très clairement Wian
elle a pas l'air de je sais pas pourquoi
elle accepte à chaque fois jouer ses
compètes peut-être les les Chinois qui
oblige la Fédération j'en sais rien
moi parce qu'elle a jamais l'air
d'être d'être heureuse
quoi quand tu as joue ses compètes
pourquoi dame prend y parce que ça
ferait tour prend C7 qui attaquerait le
fou c'est mieux de pousser fou prend
C7 et là il y a G5 et G4 qui gagne
instantanément une
pièce qui marchait pas au coup d'avant
parce que sur G5 il y avait E4
dame prend 4 tour
dame B7 prend C7 en
fait qui chassa la dame de la diagonale
et qui permettait de gagner le pion et
du coup après cavalier A6 ça lui a
permis d'avoir le G5 donc elle va gagner
une pièce pas facile avoir
G5 faire
G4
et du coup elle va aller choper
B6 t pris une Mao niveau 3 ouais mais
pas simple à voir jessco en blitz en
longue c'est pas très dur mais en blitz
c'est pas
simple c'est bien
jouet
c'est bien joué fan qui va peut-être
prendre
l'avantage si c'est la dernière partie
de la cadence après tout va jouer en
bulette de toute façon c'est souvent la
cadence enfin c'est forcément la cadence
déterminante dans les matchs
serrés et donc du coup elle va réussir à
prendre la
pièce et ça va faire pièce de plus je
pense qu'elle va prendre du pion essayer
de garder les dames et magouillassz mais
normalement il y a rien le buê le Bullet
c'est du 1+
1 normalement ça c'est tranquille et
Ciao
landive
ça BO un peu tôt côté bibi
Sarah allez il faut trouver une
magouille là avec les
Blancs cavalier qui revient en
B8
terrible terrible terrible
c'est vraiment pièce de plus mais ouais
faut conclure je sais pas si j'irais pas
sur du Fou pr à
3 pour bouffer le
pion tour B1 tour C8 il va avoir quoi
tour
B5 fou des
deux c'est vraiment la vraie pièce de
plus
hein il peut y avoir aurait pu avoir du
cavalie 5 il prend F3 je
pense cavalier qui va à la dame qui va
venir en
E4 dame D1 cavalier D7 elle galère un
peu à
finir mais bon elle va pouvoir faire
rentrer les
pièces libisara doit essayer de jouer
vite MRE son adversaire mal
autant est-ce qu'il y a un micro dans la
pièce oh tu sais s'il y avait une une
mini
oreillette de toute façon tuentendrais
rien et tu verrais
rienin bon écoutez ça bouge les pièces
hein est-ce que que on va réussir à
s'éviter une une une partie de plus non
on aura une dernière partie quand même
dans la
cadence on en aura une de
plus bah après je pense je pense pas que
les joueux une aide extérieur sur ces
parties après bon c'est vrai
que c'est vrai que le doute est toujours
permis hein c'est c'est normal mais là
la vue du niveau de jeu c'est quand même
un peu fort de café après c'est quand
même dans le domaine du possible
hein oh non ça va pas trop vite pour
tricher dans tous les cas mais mais bon
là le niveau de jeu t t tempend à
laisser penser qu'il y a r après ça peut
être bien fait aussi
hein ça retourne toujours dans cette
position de l'Espagnol qui me semblait
plutôt bien se passer pour wiifan quand
même globalement même si elle a perdu
quelques parties en
tropant
donc ça
échange
alors pour le Top 12 après juste pour
expliquer pourquoi il y a il y a aussi
peu de
joueurs pe joueur autant de de
joueurs supposé moins fort et donc avec
des classements plus FAI parce que cette
année il y a pas de de relégation donc
les clubs qui jouent pas vraiment la
victoire ont pu décider d'envoyer des
équipe un peu moins forte parce que de
toute façon ils peuvent pas être
relégués du coup ceci expliquant
cela c'est pour ça qu'il peut y avoir
des équipes qui qui on envoyé des
composition un petit peu plus plus
faible qu'habituellement
ou non il y a pas de il y a pas de
relégation cette
année donc c'est pour ça que les les
clubs ont décidé de dépenser un peu
moins d'argent
certains
genre là par exemple Fab il joue contre
un joueur qui est classé
2182 ça devrait turbo
gagner ça devrait turbo
gagner pour Fab
ouais 2180 normalement c'est un peu
faible mais bon après faut faire gaffe
hein il y a beaucoup de jeunes joueurs
qui ont pu euh baisser euh
qui qui ont pu ne ne pas prendre leur
gagn en hlo pardon et avoir un hlo plus
faible que leur valeur
réelle donc ça peut être un 2180 qui
joue en réalité plutôt à 22 50 23 et
donc qui peut être qui peut être
dangereux
bon c'est une belle position pour
IFAN qui a perdu quelques parties sur
des gaffes mais qui là semble retrouver
de sa
superbe B après les parties il faut pas
trop regarder les les évaluations des
des positions après après quelques coups
avec les Noirs c'est jamais simple
he de prendre
l'avantage c'est le genre de position
elle a souvent fini par perdre ou
fan
on va voir comment elle
continue pas si simple à
gagner prend 4 F
prend4 prend4 fou
C3 voilà voir quelque chose que je
rate peut-être elle veut juste dame C7
et tour7 hein
ok3 voir juste dame C7 c'est peut-être
très bien jouer
ça
F5 elle veut
elle veut tout resette mais bon il y a
pas vraiment de
ma vous frin non Laurent il a une
position normale en fait c'est juste la
théorie Alex raconte un peu de la merde
en en vrai je sais pas s'il comprend
vraiment les parties qu'
regardent position elle est juste
normale juste une position égale
descossais qui tend vers la nul
azo emazo ah mais tien il joue contre un
joueur à 2000 260 c'est
terrible mais non il est pas moins bien
Laurent c'est
égal sa à rien la position
emazo emazo azo azo je trouve pas
et Mao je trouve
pas j'arrive pas j'arrive pas à le
trouver ça va tenir côté bibi SAR qui av
une nouvelle fois une une position
dramatique
mais ça va faire perpète sur dam je
crois il y a dame prend E7 ah elle veut
rentrer dans cette finale c'est risqué
he pour
ifanos position normale bon j'arrive pas
à le trouver mais peu importe ouais ça
m'étonnerait faut pas regarder les éval
d'ordi à la sortie de de l'ouverture les
blancs auront toujours un avantage
surtout sur les petites turbines
être égal face à matre feed c'est bof
bof ah bah oui mais bon comment tu veux
faire dans l'ouverture quand tu as les
Noirs tu peux rien faire là je regarde
j'ai pas vu la position de Mazo mais la
position de Laurent qu'est- tu veut
qu'il fasse il joue une écosaise machin
il joue une variante que moi aussi je
joue quand quand j'ai besoin de faire
nul contre un mec plus fort donc c'est
dur de prendre
l'avantage bon du coup ça finit sur nul
7 etnemi 6 ETI allez on se remet une
petite pause et on revient dans 5
minutes pour le retour du match et pour
les
bullettes
et voilà on est de retour les amis ça a
repris ça repris avant que avant que
j'arrive j'avais mis réveil à 15h30 mais
ils ont repris un petit peu en avance
bizarrement allez on va suivre la fin du
match
ou fan qui est devant de un
point qui va peut-être faire la
différence dans les bullettes oh la la
dame ne peut plus défendre le cavalier
allez ça va gagner allez dame pr g5o
c'est
terminado faut-il le voir ouis
normalement le voir he puis on prend et
puis on prend des tris c'est quand même
assez
simple y avait déjà une caloche de
plus allez ça part allez oui fan il faut
faire la différence maintenant histoire
de de boucler ce match le plus vite
possible allez on va être à fond tiens
joue le petit G3 comme vladier allez on
va être à fond pour la jouée chinoise
maintenant on sait pas trop pourquoi
mais allez pour pour que
mathématiquement soit fini le plus vite
allez ça va rocker tour norm c'est bibi
Sara qui est plus forte en bulette mais
bon IFAN étant une plus forte joueuse
globalement en match ça peut être un peu
différent qui domine ambulette W lesau
Alex
kokar ben ou elle est sympa elle une
tête sympa je sais pas mais bon bibisar
a l'air sympa aussi hein c'est les deux
ont l'air cool mais allez on est un peu
pour IFAN histoire d'être pour quelqu'un
le dequatro qui part puis on prend
cavalier prank qui prend fou prend ça
mettre la
pression euh du coup non il y a pas eu
fou D5 c'est moi qui est troll avec avec
le clic mais D4 joué dame C8 est-ce
qu'il a pas du D5 tour
D8 prise B6 dame 2 prise D5 prise D5
prise D5 voilà pris E5 prix E5
elle peut peut-être prendre E5 prendre
B6
pr c'est pas fait du cavalier
des5 attention
f32 c'est pas jouer mais là c'est chaud
un peu de
partout peut
marcher C3 maintenant ou là c'est pas vu
mais cavalier 4 du coup qui
[Musique]
couvre63
ouais ouais non allez c'est chaud 28
secondes chacune allez fous co non elle
prend ou là elle ramène le pion ici mais
G5 fou D5 elle veut peut-être cavalier
F6 fou pr fou fou prend D5 damage5 ouais
ça ambulette c'est mieux pour les blancs
clairement c'est beaucoup plus facile à
jouer peut-être un petit tour D1 marlou
tour D1 peut être très marlou ça menace
cavalier 6 fou D5 et ça menace t prend
D6 du coup elle va prendre D6 la mar
n'est jamais
finie pr à damage 5 sur H6 a prise le
fou4 ça donne l'impression de
a pris H7 pr
h74ut G6 du coupre mieux de le faire
dans l'autre sens tour
F5 mal jou de la part de qui a pris un
poil trop de risque maintenant c'est
gagnant pour bibi
le cavalier qui pe arrive en D4 t prend5
C3 bien joué allez il faut essayer
d'aller attaquer le roi advverse tour D5
c'est bien joué t prend B5 il y a fou D3
ça ça a été raté parce que maintenant il
y a pion B passer alors il faut envoyer
les pions passés rapidement là tour C5
c'est un temps de perdu peut-être t C5
tour D5 elle veut faire tour D7 tour C7
tour B7
peut-être F3 pas mal
penser tour D8 3 F7 puis on prend fou
prend tour B8 allez il faut bloquer le
pion il faut avancer ces
pions ça c'est pas grave c'est de l'eau
absolue r
F2 fou C6 c'est ce que T reprend B5 fait
nul ce serait
culoté je pense qu'elle veut essayer
d'aller échanger le pion elle se dit
qu'avec fou cavalier elle m'attrape pas
en face ce qui est loin d'être idiot en
fait
faut faire gaffe de pas laisser trop
avancer le
pion mais clairement normalement ça va
pas mat là tour prend B5 maintenant
c'est les blancs qui jouent le
gain le
gain façon de parler mais c'est les
blanc qui presse elle peut faire un tour
ah elle a pas tour PR 6 elle fait H5
maintenant prend E6 et G4 ouais ça va
faire la petite
DRAO petite
DRAO plutôt un bon résultat ici pour euh
pour
ouifan plus 18 minutes de de P de de de
points de
plus allez ça joue du roi F1 ça joue de
l'ambulant avec H4 bien joué de la part
de Bibi bibi qui
envoie allez FA CIS cavalier7 ça joue
solide côté IFAN mais ce genre de
position dure à jouer en en bullette
avec les
noirs allez F prend H6 BIM allez là faut
envoyer la bibi S c'est F prend H6 au
prochain allez BIM bah BIM pu on prend
dame prend allez BIM BIM BIM BIM BIM
allez allez
bibi allez bibià c'est pas bibi de jouer
mais elle l'empêche maintenant allez G
qui trop là faut envoyer faut pas
réfléchir interdit de gâcher
munitions allez G4 32 tour G1 G5 ah non
mais là faut pas réfléchir déjà le F H6
par cavalier H2 c'est mou c'est mou
c'est mou chez mou là ce qu'elle fait
c'est extrêmement
mou elle laisse elle laisse complètement
fan se
réorganiser allez
on arrête la
molesse c'est mou comme du nougamou tout
c cette histoire allez il faut envoyer
allez ma petite bibi allez ma petite
bibi
non là c'est trop tard tout est
réorganisé côté noir c'est fan qui va
jouer la gagne peut-être même terrible
elle a raté le foupr H6 qui était à
roganesque là ça gâche les munitions
alors que c'est
interdit ça va
échanger ça va probablement encore
échanger roi
H6 faroage6 direct qui est aussi
jouable il fou G4 maintenant et tour F3
ok dommage pour elle elle a raté fou G4
qui était vraiment fort mais bon ça va
finir par gagner les pions ils sont tous
sur
blanc mais fou G4 jamais non F4 non
elle a pas voulu rentrer elle a vu un
trou elle n'est pas rentrée dedans
ouais
terrible
terrible terrible terrible elle est pas
vraiment rentré mais bon maintenant faut
qu'elle voit qu' prend C4 et tour
F3 pas
vu ça
vendange oh là là elle est obligé de
faire t prend level de la partie à la
fin é éta hallucinant ça raté ça troll
ça continue à troller ça trollé le pion
là elles ont elles ont trollé de ouf
toutes les deux dur de savoir qui va
gagner cette partie maintenant les
blancs sont mieux mais il y a eu
tellement d'erreurs ça peut terminer en
nul quand il y a beaucoup de fautes
comme ça
Z joue vite
maintenant c'est bien ce que font les
blancs ici
c'est bien ce que fait
an la partie qui dure et ouais ça finit
par un TR fois la même position et ça
finit par une nulle ça trollle des deux
côtés c'est fou d'avoir raté le prend C4
pour pour donner une pièce de coup
après
c'est très
dommage bon il y a quoi il y a deux
points d'écart il reste 14 minutes il y
a pas de ah non c'est au noir de jouer
pardon je me suis perdu mais elle menace
des5 du coup des5 des Noirs peut-être
pas mal
joué ça échange de partout
F45 qui va
partir allez peut-être du dame G4 tour
ouais tour G3 allez allez
où dame H5 aura pu faire dame G4 elle
met la dame en H5 c'est bien aussi
maintenant la tour en F1 et on va
essayer de faire F5
F6
allez F5
F6 peut-être même c'est abusé mais F5 F6
ça
part F6 fait pas F6
F6 G6 elle peut prendre prendre prendre
elle reprendra D3 à la
fin
ouais et T prend
des3 dame F7 et dame prend tour D7 t
prend G7 prend
B7 et ça abandon bibisara qui veut pas
perdre trop de temps mais 12 minutes àer
balles de match maintenant parce qu'il
reste qure parties
max mais elle joue nettement mieux wi
fan elle a mieux joué nettement mieux
joué tout le match mais après elle
elle a beaucoup
gaffé et là heureusement elle arrête un
peu de gaffer et ça fait tout de suite
la DIF là par contre 5 ça fait mal hein
parce qu'il y a le pion H7 derrière
allez elle va rester en vie dans cette
partie dans ce match bibara si elle
gagne
je pense en vrai tu dois tenter
prise mais bon
a non c'est horrible
elle a raison de faire ça de laisser la
caloche et de
elle veut jouer la qualité de moins mais
les cases avec les cavales
ok c'est un bon choix pratique de la
part d'an elle joue bienan là
5 c'est bien provoque pr à 8 c'est très
bien joué la partan lui prend pas la
tour ce qui je pense est bien jouer pour
du Bullet en tout cas j'imagine qu'elle
va tenter F6 elle doit ouvrir PR5 et
Esser de s'ouvrir la tour et jouer
l'activité avec la dame qui arrivera en
H4 tu dois t'activer fait
F5 bon c'est un peu le truc est-ce que
tu prends est-ce que tu prends pasre
elle peut prendre maintenant
et maintenant elle fait damage 4 ok ouis
il fallait prendre à tô ou
tard peut-être F6 était plus plus malin
pour essayer d'ouvrir et mettre le le
bordel parce que maintenant c'est
vraiment une qualité propre de plus et
c'est tour G5 tour G1 dame 2 ou tour G3
tour G1 il y a pas d'attaque pour les
noirs
elle blinde quand même elle va essayer
de jouer le plus longtemps possible elle
met la tour en G5 qui aurait été mieux
placé directement sur cette
case le roi qui se barre elle va ramener
la dame en H8 pour défendre je
pense et maintenant le pion H qui arrive
inéluctablement bon malheureusement on a
un truc qui est venu décaler les cames
euh
ouais bon
bravo bravo la production
terrible mais la position est
complètement gagnante la tour va arriver
en G6 et le pion H6 le grand
classique allez prend F4 prend G7 tour
prend t
prend prend G2 là il y a G8
encore ça peut encore jouer un petit peu
un chou c'est bien joué ici
mais apparemment il lui manque le pion
à3 allez elle joue un coup de
défense mais ça va en être de trop pour
an qui s'incline
allez encore de points désolé pour les
cam là c'est complètement
indépendant de ma
volonté la production américaine qui a
qui a fait une une erreur technique mais
c'est pas grave le français qui va
réussir à à remettre les choses à leur
place
ouais non la position elle devait
peut-être prendre parce que F6 éétait
peut-être relou ouais ouais F6 ça pouit
être dangereux ais je pense ça a été
plus dangereux mais
après je pas le cheval il revient vers3
en
fait allez il va falloir va falloir
faire le taf côté
où il va pas oh non ils ont rechangé les
cam oh c'est pas
possible oh là là la technique
américaine en
sueur ça su côté américain
ça su côté production américaine mais ça
ne fait pas peur au
français allez c'est là oùan elle
recommence à faire du
caca attention elle réfléchit beaucoup
pour pas grandchose
ah des55 bien joué erreur de
Bibi là ça va prendre en
D5 peut-être du cavalier G4 du cavalier
F5 qui peuvent partir qui prend F5 dame
prend
F5 ça
part euh dame prend H5 cavalier G6 inou
cavalier E7 inou prend C8 et ça va faire
gain du match pour euh pour la joueuse
chinoise oh ça abandonne inst stant
terrible mais TR points d'écart 7
minutes oh il y a peut-être encore un
micronde
il y a un micromonde encore bibi Sara
qui qui abandonne rapidement c'est pas
bête de la part de
Bibi
allez pass égalité où là on va éviter on
va éviter les égalités il y a plus
S mais ouais on peut dire quean a fait
la la pluie et le BE dans ce match elle
a surtout fait la pluie
elle a raté quand même pas mal d'occas
elle a un peu
troll mais finalement c'est
passé c'est passé c'est pas encore fini
fini mais là
maintenant plus faut qu'elle gagne des
parties rapides
bibisara la K C5 elle mas prend des TR
et dame prend C4
va devoir jouer un B3 mais qui est
tellement moche avoir des B5 et problème
sur le cavalier
C3 c'est B5 qui va partir
maintenant même pas t F8
bizarre très
bizarre B5 pouvait peut-être gagner sur
le
champ on ça joue solide côté
IFAN est-ce qu'elle va envoyer le D5
peut-être c'est peut-être le momentum là
pour envoyer D5 pas faut calculer
complexe non elle se décide pas pour le
moment
replace ça elle va prendre de la
tour peut-être déprend5
ouais ok il y a pas de les fous sont
fort mais il y a rien de clair évident
bien pas prend
B6 l'impression qu'il dit tu été matrixé
par fans es abo à qui du
coup il a été
matrixé
ça reprend plus que 2 secondes 04 pour
bibi
Sara en plus le problème c'est que ça
elle
tombe position était difficile
après
terminado c'est terminé les amis elle ne
pourra plus revenir 3 points d'écart
terminé
je suis pas sur ce service en plus je
sais
pas CLUD qui connaît le
service alle 4 points d'écart il y avait
TR points oua j'étais en train de dire
une victoire ça revenait à de points et
ça suffisait même pas en fait maisà 4
points d'écart c'est terminé les
amis bon ben match bizarre on a senti
IFAN c'était pas du tout sa cadence et
qu'elle était pas à l'aise dans ce dans
ce type de jeu BL c'est et bullette euh
mais elle est tellement plus forte aux
échecs hein que que ça suffit à à
carry on va voir voà la partie à plus
grand en jeu
le match est
plié le match est plié il reste quoi il
reste il pourra jamais y avoir faudrait
qu'elle en gagne 3 en 2 minutes 37 c'est
impossible c'est absolument impossible
il faudrait de points d'écart il y
aurait encore eu un shot elle pouvait
gagner ça en
230 il y avait encore un petit shot mais
mais là
non là c'est mort
ouifan nit pas méga concerné par le
match ouais mais bon elle rapport va
avoir quasiment 200 points fit de plus
en longue et même si c'est pas sa
cadence ça ça suffit ce que je disais
généralement on peut perdre 100 points
mais pas pas vraiment beaucoup plus et
même si son adversaire gagne 100 points
du coup entre avec l'écart dans le
meilleur des monde elle joue au même
niveau en blitz mais on a senduif tu pas
beaucoup beaucoup plus forte mais un peu
plus
forte ah c'est difficile he pour bibi
Sara le match est plié et bon faud
peut-être rejouer encore une partie
après pour être bien
sûr elle a vraiment dominé dans cette
game avec les noirs
a deion de plus ah
prend 8 en
un
démobiliser ou tour B1 dame
D1 là je pense qu'elle joue encore
quelques coup parce qu'elle aimerait
bien que ce soit la dernière partie mais
malheureusement il y en aura encore une
derrière malheureusement pour elle il
faudra encore en jouer une
derrière pe comprendre qu'elle
soit de de devoir jouer encore une
partie mais c'est le
cas
obligé mais ouais ben ou on a pensé à
une surprise à un moment donné au début
des bullettes on s'est un peu enflammé
puis finalement ça
déroulin
terminado quand so démoralisant contre
mais qui gagne c'est comme quand je
perds contre un certain ikarou quand il
lit son
chat il son chat et il défonce ikarou
terrible quand il y a trop d'écart en
fait c'est dur de
combler pas énorme énorme
mais suffisamment grand pour
que pour qu'elle puisse rien
faire il y avait plus d'écart dans le
match qu'on a suivi hier et là du coupik
contre Michou écoute on va repartir pour
3h de bonheur plaisir 3h de Stream qui
part là
encore un petit
6h
ça fait quand même très
plaisir oh c'est magnifique
hein c'est
magnifique
apr Ctait sympa ça fait que commencer on
est on est à mi-chemin là
ouais donc c'est parti complètement
anecdotique j'ai pas vraiment regardé
honnêtement
clairement le match est déjà plié depuis
un petit quart
d'heure mais il faut encore terminer la
position bien joué le le décalage de la
tour
ça prendre
F7 allez D7 là ça finit le taf ça fait
une double
attaque je crois qu'elle voit plus
rien la pauvre je crois qu'elle est au
bout du
rouleau psychologiquement c'est
relou
allez ça gagne autant ça se termine
là-dessus donc victoire 13 à 9 victoire
tranquille de W fan finalement on a
senti un peu en dedans mais ça suffit
pour gagner ça suffira pas contre Katia
par
contre du coup je fais une petite pause
parce que l'autre match commence très
bientôt et je reviens tout de suite
après pour la suite et bah rester il y a
quand même 3h 3h de bonheur à venir 3h
de match ce serait quand même très
dommage de rater le deuxème match les
amis donc à tout de suite pour la
suite
bon les gars on va
repartir
on va repartir pour je v pas mettre les
noms pour le moment parce qu'on sait
jamais si ça va changer de
Cam on va repartir pour 3h de match là
3h de
compète
magnifique qui turbo gagne ah bah ouais
mais c'est sûr que
2100 c'est pas assez contre
Fab niveau pas assez fort contre
Fab c'est c'est un niveau trop faible
pour lutter face aux
Français voir sa
game
c'est pas fini fini encore la partie de
Fab mais il est bien
quoi il peut se mettre en PLS à tout
moment
j'espère que les caméras vont être dans
le bon sens attendez peut-être que le
match a commencé en vrai j'ai oublié que
les
parties se lançit pas
automatiquement mais je crois
pas mais je ne crois pas
du
coup non ça joue pas en voie sur les cam
fa ger le titre
ouais c'est
exact
ouais allez il reste 3h 3h de match on
va ça va être palpitant ça va être
palpitant mou vs
harica
ch et
Harik et
Arik c'est pile de
laap
terrible on va voir ce que ça donne
hein
on va voir ce que ça donne il fait très
chaud là chez
moi bonne journée à toi ça ser peut-être
une petite heure là j'ai déjà la
migraine donc je sais pas ce soir si je
comptais stream à 19h2 19h à 20h30 avant
le match de rugby me faire un peu PL sur
des Blitz et tout pour me nettoyer le
cerveau mais je suis pas sûr que j'ai
déjà mal à la tête du coup ce soir je
sais pas à faire
abstraction je sais pas
encore je suis pas sûr il smoule mais en
tout cas il va y avoir une compétition
là qui va partir on aura besoin de toi
euh contre les bras en 4 V4 on aura
grand besoin de toi
ismou je t'écrirai c'est jeudi
normalement 21h j'attends la
confirmation des
du bras gauche à
Man je sais pas s'il va voir ça avec son
bras
droit bon du coup je pas à parle B on
attend que ça démarre
he
c'est pas parti
encore
donc on attend que ça démarre viment ça
pas ça pas commencé
encore le Tour de France qui démarre
demain
dit qui a l'air de rigoler plus ou moins
je sais pas je la sens
sourire
on attend le début du
match
impatiemment ils ont décalé les caméras
je crois je vois pas les parties en fait
ça y est c'est parti est-ce que les
cames vont rebouger ou pas je pense
pas je vais choper les cames comme
ça haricade elle est mal cadrée de toute
façon on la verra
pas
on verra pas mieux que
ça et m par contre on la voit
bien qu'on la voit pas
mal je crois que ça être dame B6 non
c'est5 pris et ça doit
aller
anoncer son alors que les bras prennent
leur décision euh
ouais ouais mais ça va être le match
avec avec notre format là qui va être
assez cool malheureusement j'ai peur que
ça tombe après un speitchess féminin euh
c'était quand les finales déjà j'ai peur
qu'en fait la date qu'on est décidé soit
Prin pit féminin donc jeais pas
forcément la meilleure des humeurs euh
faites voir je vais vous dire en fait je
vais regarder au moins vous saurez quand
quand ça
termine ça va aller pour les
Noirs normalement mais après les dates
elles sont tout le temps modifiées hein
ouais c'est jeudi premier ouais c'est le
2 le 1 le 2 le 3 c'est terrible mais on
n pas encore les heures
malheureusement
malheureusement il y a pas encore les
heuresprès ce qui est cool c'est que la
la finale sera dans le format plus long
comme ça le match il durera il durera
3h30 aller bouffer le pion en B 3
pendant que je regardais
ça on va voir comment ça continue
ah la petite pube qui est partie c'est
cool
ça donc il a pion de plus mais c'est dur
la tour va arriver en A1 et il va elle
va faire cavalier à 5 pour qu' prend
C6 ça peut être chiant à
jouer pour les
noirs on va voir comment continue avec
les
Noirs il y a plus trop de discussion
dans le chat là c'est tendu complexe
c'est
complexe très complexe
ok
t
très complexe comme
position 4 c'est marrant on avait on
avait un peu des viewers là pour le
premier match là ça tombe complètement
je crois le deuxème match a complètement
découragé tout le monde les gens sont
partis et ils ont bien eu raison ou
pas suivant ce qu'ils ont à faire mais
j'ai l'impression que ça a découragé pas
mal de monde le deuxième match qui
commence
les deux en même temps ça fait ça fait
ça fait mal
clairement de matchs comme ça qui
s'enchaînent ça fait
mal un match fait
mal
mais c'est vrai que
de de c'est c'est très très complexe
match consécutifs c'est très
complexe avec Vlad c'était cool live
hier avec Vlad
c'était très
cool le A3 de staronian je crois le A3
de Lévon
ouais mais c'est vrai que c'était
marrant le
A3 le A3 est tu es très
drôle c'est fou comme erreur
là l' bien amené
ouais là j'aurais été à deux doigts de
réfléchir à grand RCK
qui devait perdre mais qui était
marrant non mais ce qui était marrant
avec le A3 c'est que c'est qu'en fait il
y avait le cavalier G3 dont je parle au
début qui pouvait jouer
aussi il il y avait il y avait dame G6
en fait il y a tout un tas de coup
logique mais à 3 c'était vraiment le
coup le moins logique de
tous
et ça va être dur pour les Noirs
ouais à3 était vraiment
bizarre
c'était
marrant ça doitre plus ou moins égal ce
truc là infin mais je prendrai les je
sais pas si je prendrai les noirs ou les
blancs en fait ça dépend si on réussit à
gagner C6 ou pas mais est-ce qu'on peut
faire k pr pion k prend t B6 qui
des43
je sais pas ça se calcule c'est
complexe fa qu' F3 qui
6 K 5 K
C5
on va voir les cames sont inversé ben en
fait on sait pas encore c'estik qui a
les blancs mais on sait pas dans quel
sens sera le match en
fait
sais pas pourquoi tu es bann faut voir
avec les modos samirkanovic j'en sais
rien doit y avoir une bonne
raison on va faire c D4 ici
ok Tage li
de les des C ouais je pense c'est les
noir qui joue plutôt le gain
maintenant peut-être que tu es plutre
ouais c'est pas mal parce que du coup
sur tour 8 F3 il y aura rage rage
ah bah si tu as été ban c'est que
c'était mérité he
mirkanovic est-ce que tu étais sub la
question de base non mais
euh généralement ils banniss Bent pas
des bandf pour
rienin pour une band faut y aller hein
bon ça peut gagner d'un côté ou de
l'autre
hein d enfin pas grave c'est que c'est
que tu assumes pas
hein ça n'assume pas à côté mirkanovic
ouais il faut faire gaffe
prend 4 cavalier ah ou roi E3
5 qui prendre D3 c'était peut-être pas
nul mais comme ça
oui ro prend F4 il faut faire et D2
cavalier G4 cavalier F2 et c'est dro
instant
ouais roi des deux a été joué tempo
elle a fait ro prend des de tempo ce qui
veut dire que si elle avait fait D1
cavalier dame elle aurait gagné D1
cavalier pas dame roi prend d de aurait
été possible et du coup elle aurait
gagné ça aa été tellement marlou des
deux
cavaliers parce que dame ouais ça
marchait pas mais cavalier ça marchait
c'est un truc de marlou faut que je m'en
rappelle
il faut que je m'en rappelle parce que
la marloutri n'est jamais finie tu
l'aurais tenté non tu aurais pas
pensé mais maintenant j'y
penserai tellement
marlou
bon c'est un
dragon c'est les grandes
variantes ah ouais non sur ch il il
mette beaucoup de pub hein c'est vrai il
met énormément de
pub bon c'est le dragon ça joue
dit une blague sur mvl mais ça être une
blague un peu reloue et ça devait pas
être la première hein il avait dû
prendre des TH avant déjà
5 TJ faire gaffe au cavalier D5 ici qui
peuvent
RER avec le pion F7 quand prend F7 et
qu'on devra reprendre la dame le
problème c'est que le roi pourra prendre
al que quand il doit partir en H ça peut
marcher
est-ce que tu comptes aller chercher le
titre de maîre Fed non je le considère
pas en fait je considère aucun titre à
part grand maître et j'ai pas le temps
de j'ai j'ai juste pas envie dans ma vie
de perdre plus d'années que ça à faire
des échecs compétitifs donc non mais le
titre de Maître fit criminal Bishop je
le considère pas en fait je considère
pas que ça
existe
c'est pas un titre que
[Musique]
je que je considérerai
obtenir mettrep moi je considéreris pas
non plus mais
bon je le considère pas non plus même le
titre de Grand- maître il est tellement
dévalué maintenant mais du coup le titre
de Grand Maître est tellement dévalué
que c'est vraiment le seul et unique qui
peut
avoir de l'intérêt
quoi
globalement
donc
ça
échange en vra c'est déjà sympa faut pas
abuser ouais c'est commême avoir le bac
quoi c'est cool mais ça sert à r c'est
rien en fait c'est pas un niveau hein
c'est pas un niveau de jeu
hein non mais c'est bien d'avoir le
brevet des du collège aussi ou le bac
c'est cool mais
bon
c'est mieux d'avoir B + 5 quand
même non i c'est
pas ça joue vraiment à partir de grand
matre tuas bag plus 5 non mais si tu
fais des études tu le fais vraiment si
tu veux devenir pro aux échecs tu le
fais vraiment j'enis déjà parlé 1000
fois si j'a voulu devenir prox échecs il
aurait fallu pour moi que j'ai au moins
2650 ce que je pouvais pas faire sinon
en fait à quoi ça sert
juste pas une
grandchose et je pouvais pas le
faire
malheureusement donc j'ai quit
d'un point vue commercial j'aurais pensé
que ça être d'avoir le titre de MF ou mi
peut-être pour certains mais bon enfin
moi j'en ai pas besoin
quoi peut-être ça peut servir hein je je
sais pas moi j'ai jamais eu besoin avant
que avant que j'ai ma chaîne qui marche
et CETA j'en ai pas eu besoin pour
donner des cours et bon maintenant ok
juste c'est assez évident que j'en ai
plus du tout besoin mais
honnêtement
non est-ce que dans son par la qualité
de tes coaches a été un frein pour
prendre la
aré non au contraire les gens qui me
coachaient ils étaient plutôt non
c'était normal d'arrêter en
fait c'était plutôt cool pour mes coach
c'était plutôt cool d'arrêter
aussi ce qui était une ce qui était une
bonne chose hein ce qui était plutôt un
bon conseil tu regrettes pas un peu non
c'est la meilleure décision que j'ai
prise dans ma vie je
pense du
coup du coup c'était vraiment une
excellente décision ça c'était vraiment
une bonne décision c'estut-être la la
meilleure décision entre guillemets
professionnel que j'ai
prise ça aurait été terrible de
continuer et euh et du coup
non et tu as bien vécu de te rendre
compte que tu étais pas assez bon bon ça
été une prise de conscience si tu veux
mais mais après une fois que tu en as
pris conscience et que tu le sais ça va
non ça
va c'était
cool c'était cool en fait il vaut mieux
s'arrêter plutôt que de de s'enfermer
dans une mauvaise direction en fait
c'est pas forcément facile au premier
abord parce que tu as tuas tu as dépensé
beaucoup de temps et d'énergie mais il
vaut mieux chercher savoir et
recommencer de zéro quand tu as 18 ans
plutôt que plutôt que quand tu en a 35
ou 40
hein et connaissant mon caractère pour
moi ça aurait été terrible d'avoir fait
que des échecs dans ma vie en fait
j'aurais j'aurais tellement eu
l'impression d'avoir ser ma
life donc non non avec le recul c'était
vraiment baisse
décision
je me serais jamais imaginé faire que
des échecs toute ma vie tu vois et du
coup j'ai pu avoir plein d'expérien
sympa
et et du coup découvrir plein d'autres
choses et c'était c'était vraiment super
ou PIST sont les coups irrécupérables
ouais ça c'est un concept hyper dur à
comprendre en tant qu'être le concept
des coup irrécupérable du coup je fais
quoi j'ai bossé dans une galerie d'art
j'ai bossé dans un restaurant
euh j'ai une carrière de joueur de
poker j'ai fait quoi j'ai découvert
d'autres
trucs aussi au-delà de
ça j'ai eu envie mais s pas réalisé de
de vendre du
thé et euh et j'aurais pu faire masse de
choses quand j'ai arrêté de streamer
j'ai des cours d'échec dans des écoles
primaires
j'ai bossé à la feed j'ai vendu des
échiqu avec la feed je fais plein de
trucs
différents du coup je fais plein de
trucs différents j'ai rencontré plein de
gens j'ai eu plein d'expériences
différentes c'était vraiment
super
puis j'ai vécu à l'étranger aussi du
coup j'ai vécu 10 ans en Russie donc en
fait il y a plein d'expériences dont je
vous ai parlé qui étaent en Russie donc
c'était non seulement
des non seulement des expériences
enrichissantes mais aussi des des
expériences
dans dans un pays étranger du coup
ouis j'ai écrit un livre aussi du coup
enfin c'est Sami qui l'a écrit mais
finalement en quelque sorte je suis
co-auteur du livre donc j'ai écrit un
livre aussi tu vois dans toutes les
choses ce que j'ai pu
faire c'est mieux que d'avoir juste
jouer aux échecs quoi
comment vivent les euh Baky MV je pense
qu'il le vit bien Vlad Vlad il le vit
assez mal en fait d'avoir fait que des
échecs ça dépend des gens Fab je dirais
que il semi regret enfin pas il regrette
mais Fab ou il aimerait bien faire
d'autres choses aussi Mathieu par
exemple lui il kiffe ça dépend des gens
mais Fab ouvlade par exemple bah avec
les les deux avec lesquels je suis le
plus proche ouais ça les saoule d'avoir
fait que enfin que des
échecs d'avoir une vie vraiment
vraiment quasiment que autour des
échecs
donc non non mais ça dépend des gens
tuas tu as des gens qui vont bien le
vivre tu as d'autres gens qui vont moins
bien le vivre et moi c'était cool que je
l'ai compris quand j'avais 18 ans et pas
et pas quand tu en a 35 40 parce
qu'après ça peut être un peu trop tard
c'est la même partie avec la première
c'est assez cool pour les blancs de
base
du coup c'estik qui met on a les les
cames du bon côté
ais ça a fini par changer mais c'est les
mêmes
idées peut-être c'est comme pour tout
joueur de niau niveau dans n'importe
quel sport ben après l'avantage quand tu
as vraiment été dans le top mondial tu
vois par exemple comme mvl
euh c'est que comme tu peux engranger
beaucoup de revenus en fait tu peux
facilement faire une reconversion parce
que tu peux tu peux acheter une affaire
tu peux faire un truc c'est beaucoup
plus dur quand tu as pas été joueur du
top mondial et que tu as tu as pas tu as
pas pu mettre assez d'argent de côté
parce que du coup dans ces cas-là tu
peux te retrouver à 35 40 ans absolument
bloquer dans ton sport ça c'est c'est
terrible et c'est pour ça que j'ai
vraiment très très bien fait de
d'arrêter
parce que j'aurais jamais pu avoir un un
niveau suffisant pour gagner beaucoup
d'argent et du coup j'aurais été obligé
de de jouer aux échecs toute ma vie ça
aurait été pour moi ça aurait été un
cauchemar quoi ça aurait vraiment été
terrible pour moi ça aurait été vraiment
terrible un lanceur de JAV pense sa
reconversion aussi ouais mais c'est ça
si tu peux pas si tu peux pas engranger
assez de revenus et que tu es obligé de
faire que ça toute ta vie c'est c'est
dur alors qu'on se rend compte que tu
adores vraiment les échecs parce que tu
as fait une chaîne consacrée ouais mais
tu vois le fait de faire une chaîne
d'échec tu vois je fais plein de choses
d'autres que des échecs à côté tu vois
pour gérer ma chaîne gérer mon
entreprise et cetera j'ai plein de
choses à faire qui sont hors des échecs
qui m'apportent un un
un une richesse intellectuelle non non
pouri faire que des échecs de ma vie
enfin ça j'aurais fini enin j'aurait mal
fini quoi ça aurait pas été
possible je me serais soit complètement
remis en question soit j'aurais fini
dépressif mais c'est ça aurait pas pu
être possible
ouais c'est ça Z c'est tu vois moi j'ai
changé de voix ouais c'est pas facile
mais quand tu le fais à 18 ans ça ça va
quand tu le fais à même là tu vois
maintenant à 35 c'est plus
dur tu as beaucoup réfléchi sur cette
décision non j'ai prise assez vite je
suis allé boire deux fois avec Vlad des
coups le soir il m'a expliqué que
j'étais nul et que m'attendait une vie
il m'a un peu décrit la vie qui
m'attendait et on sa'est ouais ça s'est
passé en deux soirées je
pense il des tournois un après les
autres des prépas tout le temps que des
échecs que la même chose toute ta
vie sans pouvoir jamais vraiment
atteindre le au niveau et que il m'a un
peu dépint le la vie que c'était en
réalité
et il a il a bien fait et et du coup euh
bah j'ai un peu réfléchi là-dessus et je
me suis rendu compte qu'il avait raison
quoi non mais c'est pour ça que tu as
des amis tu as pas des amis pour
euh pour te pépon tu as des amis pour te
dire la vérité hein ça sert à ça les
amis sert pas à te caresser dans le sens
du poil ça sert à à dire à dire les
term ça sert à dire les
termes c'est pas que j'étais nul il m'a
dit en gros pour être Simp il m'a dit en
France vous pensez que 2500 2550 c'est
fort et vous pouvez faire une carrière
avec ce niveau Vlad il m'a dit moi je te
dis que vous vivez dans un monde de
bisoun nours c'est que en dessous de 26
ans tu sais tu sais pas jouer aux échecs
tu pas bouger les pièces et que au
niveau mondial tu es personne en fait
donc en gros en gros c'était céit à peu
près ça le discours donc il m'a dit bon
bah tu peux penser qu'être grand maître
c'est bien mais il m'a dit en fait tu es
nul quand tu es grand maître c'est ça ça
ça n'a pas de valeur si tu veux il m'a
expliqué ça il m'a dit 26 50
malheureusement tu vas pas le faire il
m'a dit tu vas faire 25 25 25 25 50 tu
feras pas
2650 et du coup euh et du du coup euh et
du coup en fait il avait raison et du
coup
j'arrêtais c'est la même question
réflexion pour toute discipline qui
demande 100 % d'investissement sport
musique science bah même streamer en
fait brutal de
luxe même streamer en fait tu as des
métiers comme ça qui sont pas forcément
utiles comme joueur d'échec ou streamer
ou quoi la société vit très bien sans et
tu as besoin d'être dans les meilleurs
tu fais pas un métier qui est réellement
utile donc si non seulement c'est pas
vraiment utile
enfin c'est utile mais je parler c'est
pas indispensable et que qu'il y a des
gens qui le font mieux que toi en fait
c'est c'est tout ce genre de métier tu
es tu es pas tu es pas dedans quoi tout
ce qui est sport art et cetera c'est
comme
ça et si t était en blitz alors si t
était en blitz j'aurais continué
j'aurais peut-être pas été joueur pro
mais j'aurais continué la compétition
ouais et tous les GEM 2550 font quoi ben
ils donnent des cours et mais ils sont
bloqués en fait hein tu es tu es bloqué
dans un truc alors il y a des gens à qui
ça plaît genre Mathieu cornette ou quoi
il prend beaucoup de plaisir donc c'est
cool mais faut vraiment être beaucoup
plus passionné par les échecs que je le
suis
ouais c'est du divertissement c'est
exactement ça j'apprécie à moitié s'il y
a de la demande c'est pas inutile mais
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que ce
genre de chos en fait si tu es tu vois
si tu fais des streams d'échec en
français ou bah si tu fais des streams
en français de n'importe quoi et que tu
as 100 ou 200 viewers tu vas pas en
vivre en fait faut faut faut monter un
peu plus haut quoi et donc du coup c'est
comme tout quoi si si tu si tu as pas le
talent pour percer dans ce domaine là tu
vas pas y arriver en fait
ouais c'est ça c'est un métier comme dit
FLE ou bah faut être dans les meilleurs
dans dans ce que tu
fais et matthie des non non non il v des
des cours Mathieu aussi ah non mais si
tu es pas 2650 tu vis pas des tournois
hein tu es en en fait tu es entraîneur
d'échec tu es pas vraiment joueur
d'échec en
soit ce qui est très bien parce que il
entraîne des grands joueurs Mathieu il
entraîne des ben comme maoridi par
exemple ou
d'autres h mais mais il
faut il faut avoir un bon un très très
bon niveau que moi je n'avais
pas dans les cours aussi avec 2200
exactement avec la Castelle tu
peux tu peux mais tu tu tu vivras mieux
si tu es grand maître parce que tu
pourras mieux mieux te faire rémunéré
mais mais peut attendre peu
importe mais bon tu es obligé à un
moment donné de d'avoir une une prise de
conscience hein mais c'est vrai que en
France on pense souvent et je le vois
dans le chat que le titre de grandmître
c'est comme quoi une FA en soi alors
qu'en Russie ça va pas être le cas quoi
il y a beaucoup plus de de grands
maîtrre et de joueurs de haut niveau
il y a aucun intér entre 2005 à 2000 bah
non tu vas vendre plus cher tes cours à
2005 Nicolas NS et tu vas pouvoir jouer
des matchs par équipe où tu seras
rémunéré c'est plutôt très très bien
payé pense que si échec était aussi
suivi que d'autres sports non mais les
joueurs d'échec sont très bien payés en
fait comme j'is déjà expliqué il y a le
le système de mesena qui fait que malgré
le le le l'absence de publ les les price
pool sont sont assez élevés je crois
qu'ils sont par exemple plus élevés que
dans le snooker qui est beaucoup plus
médiatisé et tu Kevin qui défon tous
leur business provant cour sur twitch
alors non pas du tout parce que il y a
bien beaucoup de gens qui m'ont contacté
et suite au gros buzz qu'on a il y a a
il y a quelques grands maîtres et
quelques profs qui m'ont contacté pour
me remercier parce que suite au au buzz
sur twitch ah c'est énorme il y a il y a
beaucoup plus de de demandes de cours
d'échec donc au contraire ça a permis
euh tout ça a permis d' d'aider
euh certains de mes
collègues
donc je sais pas si ça je pense ça gagne
ça avec le fou mais bon va falloir
avancer les pions à un moment
donné et là il y a H6 ouais
ah ça va faire nul h bien bien
joué attention pas puis on prend puis on
prend per instante ah et maintenant il y
a tour à 7 et
G6 roi H8 et tour bouge oh il y a
zukzang ouais G6 ro H8 et tour bouge
c'est zugzang
ok il faut le voir
ok ça ça ça ça marche pas du
coup terrible d'avoir raté t G6 et tour
bouge zugzang cétait pas si dur quand
même avec une minute à la pendule
oh là là c'est terrible de te choquer
ça pourquoi elle prend pas en fait allez
tour D7 tour C7 ça gagne
elle va pas rater quand même maintenant
G6 et tour bouge ou tour bouge direct en
fait R8 et G6 maintenant c'est la même
mais dans l'autre
sens et maintenant elle peut faire pion
prend tour F 3 H6 et G7
allez t F 3 H6 ah ça fait longtemps
qu'elle a pas révidé ces finales pour
rater
ça bon ça gagne comme ça
aussi
ah je pense qu'elle est beaucoup plus
forte Harik
elle joue bien namou elle joue bien
pardon
Rik
ouais le
stress le stress le stress
sont à
l'envers je vais mettre les bons
noms allez on va espérer un massacre
dans ce
match une victoire rapide et simple de
de
harika scouam le voisson bah ça permet
de développer la dame pour faire passer
la tour en
fait bah Jamy c'est pas que ça veut rien
dire c'est qu'en fait de base le titre
de Grand Maître il était donné à 30 40
personnes aujourd'hui il a plus d'un
millier de grand mtres et tu sais que
dans les sports individuels il faut être
dans le top 50
donc disons qu'il faudrait créer un
nouveau titre quoi
supérieur top 500 ça passe au tennis ça
passe pas du tout top 500 tu es ouf
nicolases au tennis top 150 ils en
vivent pas non
plus top 500 tu vis tu vis
Pasin
tap 100 150
200 c'est top 150 au tennis top top 500
tenv pas merci Adam c'est sûr
ça don de la satisfaction personnelle
d'être GM après ça dépend dans quoi
tu plac ta
satisfaction
bon le tennis c'est le sport le plus
médiatisé au monde et le plus compétitif
les échecs ça on est bien
loin tu crois qu' GM ou Emy ça passe sur
un c ça change
rien
ah le tennis ça va être le sport le plus
individuel le plus médiatisé au monde en
tout cas c'est beaucoup plus médiatisé
AC les
échecs j' plus médiatisé enfin je sais
pas ce qui est plus médiatisé en sport
individuel que le
tennis ce qui m'impressionne c'est S et
narodisi qui sont g et en même temps on
fait des études bah en fait ils auraient
ouais là elle a filé un pion en un
mais dame à 2 céit un Jeff pigos qui a
pas été vu terrible dame
2 Formule 1 c'est plus il y a plus de
gens qui regardent la Formule 1 que
ouais mais c'est pas vraent un sport
individuel la Formule 1 en soi c'est un
sport par équipe la Formule 1 c'est pas
du tout un sport
individuel c'est un sport
d'équipe 1 c'est vraiment un sport
d'équipe d'ailleurs c'est des équipes
qui qui qui roulent en fait
c'est peut-être un pour ceux qui sont
réussi à aller faire les candidats moi
je voulais un titre auus ouais de de de
27 30 2740 quelque chose comme
ça enfin peu importe les échecs sont pas
du tout médiatisés il y a personne qui
regarde faut être sérieux
par rapport aux autres gros sports
individuels donc c'est déjà beau qu' il
y ait une centaine de personnes qui
puissent en vivre
quoi chez les mix il y a en plus une
catégorie Femme donc c'est quand même
pas
mal et bonsoir SEM
noz en fait c'est complètement foutu
pour les noir elle a filé une pièce en
un coup qui avit prend B3 dame à 2
c'était c'était une énorme
gaffe
j' prends il faut prendre des C au
prochain on prend G3 il va faire quoi il
va faire t pr va faire T prend8 et prise
G 3
ouais une pièce de
plus
haricin envoie un
front
allez s'active un peu côté côté noir
faire
gaffe
est-ce qu'elle peut tenter d'ame prend
des5 aidée sur fou prend fou prend roi
G1 tour G2 ah elle tente bien joué ça
marlou je pense ça marche pas du tout
parce qu'il y a r G1 mais c'est
marlou c'est marlou on peut pas prendre
c'est marrant comme coup c'est
joli F quel niveau ben il y a toujours
plus de d'argent dans les sports
collectif la gadep je pense qu'on joue
en National tu peux déjà en vivre donc
ça veut dire que tu as beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de gens qui théoriquement
peuvent vivre du
foot
tu prends pas la dame B si tu prends la
dame tu perds en
fait ah il y a peut-être tour F3 mais en
gros elle avait peur de
ça mais elle pouvait peut-être faire
tour F3 ici filer la tour pour se donner
la case F1
a fait fou des4 elle a sacrifié le
fou c'est pas mal sur fou F2 la fou
prend
F3 mais bon elle peut faire cavalier 3
contre échec en fait ouais mais c'est
tout de suite fini qui TR contre échec à
quoi elle
réfléchit
je comends je comprends pas à quoi elle
là je crois qu' 3 contre échec c'est sûr
que ça gagne inst stant sur C cas adame
prend C4 sinon c'est fou prend le de
ok ça va gagner pour
Michou après elle a eu raison haricade
tenté ce qu'elle a tenté il y avait des
petits pièges
hein
donc
ah c'est la petite pause là c'est la
petite pausette
en fait il y a une pause au milieu du
3+1 ils sont c'est de la
déconnexion ça trollle la
connexion c'est
terrible
complexe bon ben je vais faire une
petite pause aussi hein si ça part en
pause ça part en pause de partout
non
si ça part en pause ça part en pause de
partout
et perpétuel non parce qu'il y avait fou
F1 bon je vais faire une petite pause
hein ça c'est ça part en pause instante
hein
alors est-ce que ça a repris ou pas non
on a rien
raté les caméras il y a tout qui a
rechanger
c'est pas
possible
c'est pas possible il y a l'arbitre qui
vient
s'emmêler 3050 dans les mais c'est
pareil en fait
ou non tu dois tu dois tu dois kit si tu
es pas assez fort tu dois kit en fait si
tu veux
t'épanouir l'arbitre est hyper relou
quoi il est hyper relou avec la caméra
d'Ar
il saoule l'arbitre les
amis la petite sieste là qui pourrait
partir est-ce qu'il y a beaucoup de gens
qui qui font une petite sieste en ce
moment dans le chat est-ce que ça part
en Siesta de
partout non mais genre là en ce moment
est-ce qu'il y en a beaucoup qui partent
en
Siesta
Goran qui essaie d'expliquer à Rik qu'il
faut qu'elle soit à la
cam là ça peut partir en Siesta
hein fallir qu'on recade les caméra du
coup relou Harik à venir à partir
allez on va mettre
Michou allez ça joue reste encore une
demi-heure dans cette cadence apr on
aura 45 minutes et 25
minutes
ouais sa préparation pour le Tour de
France c'est dommage qu'il a pas le tour
aujourd'hui on aurait pu regarder
l'étape en même temps ça aurait été
tellement
cool du coup demain qui qui prend le
premier maillot
jaune personne qui répond c'est
terrible
dou ça fait bien longtemps qu'il y a
plus un Sagan voyez pas l' quand
même LAF
ambulant
bon ça a un petit peu varié dans
l'ouverture côté blanc
ou côté noir
d'ailleurs côté noir
d'ailleurs primo Dr glitch vainqueur
final tu penses qu'il va enfin
tenir les 3
semaines van derpool demain mais Van
derpool il est genre gros favori pour
l'étable de demain je comprends pas trop
pourquoi il est vraiment autant
au-dessus de ça que que alaf ou
quoi dans les arrivées en en monté comme
ça
il est genre vraiment audessus de che
auudessus quoi evanart
ok EV
enart du coup
coup mais genre vanard et
ver pa bien plus
fort en fait Alex tu mets quand même
beaucoup de messages qui servent à rien
quoi voà tu met que je suis fatigué bon
c'est pas c'est pas tant le cas mais en
fait tu écris quand même beaucoup de de
choses qui ont aucun rapport les uns
avec les autres
quoi vanerpol van vanart et alaf 1 2 3
ok pourquoi on a pas de commentaire de
la partie parce que ça dure 6h et que on
va pas faire que parler des parties hein
on parle de de choses et
d'autres c'est
long c'est
long
il pr des ce qui va
arriver terrible peêre fois 3 D6 aussi
je pense c'est déjà
fini
com bah oui forcément
c'est prend E4 cavalier D6 FO 3 qui
prend B7 et prend F8 peut-être quelque
chose comme
ça elle peut le faire avec F3 aussi
hein ces jous sont plus fort ou plus fa
en partie longue elles sont beaucoup
plus fortes et en blitz elles sont un
peu plus
faibles
ça calcule queal commence parfois à
3 ciao
Alex
col pr ça va reprendre ça va prendre 5
on va espérer qu' mettre je plus pour
dans ce match
sans avoir trop de
raison mais elle me semble avoir plus de
chance de mettre un gros score
elle me semble
plus plus forte un peu plus forte mais
après c'est plus a que les autres matchs
mais juste si elle fait la différence
elle semble pouvoir se
détacher dame
merci qui inter d'interdire ouais
c'était sympa elle était bien les
mission problème là c'est qu'il faut se
détacher du clouage pour faire
F3 de fou dans le Top 12 gag aujourd'hui
pas des mecs très fort pour le moment
après c'est cool qui
gagne mais je dois
dire il fait quoi
Fab c'est genre de partie qui gagne
généralement Fab quand même à moins de à
moins de 2003 il fait quand même très
mal
hein
à moins de 2003 il fait très
mal je suis en train de chercher sa
partie mais oui il est censé gagner fa
contre des joueurs classant en dessous
de 2200 est-ce que Fab c'est parti du
top sur sur ta chaîne euh il m'avait dit
s'il y a des beaux trucs mais je sais
pas ça il avait pas l'air d'être ultra
emballé oh ben il a gagné déjà
ouais bah là c'est une partie vraiment
facile faites voir
ouais ouais il a gagné facile la
FAB il a gagné très
facile et cette position du coup
ouais non
proprement mais pas étonnant c'est à ce
niveau là il gagne normalement assez
simplement
F est-ce que je fais un live le Top 12
non je P faire F3 G5 H4 cavalier F7
PR6 du coup prend
D3
tour point F2 dame point F2 et dame
D7 qui fait très mal ça a pas été
vu ça n'a pas été vu
ouais le classement assez bien fait
c'est ça la gadep une telle différence
de niveau normalement tu tu gagnes
tranquille non fa jusqu'à 2003
normalement ça va c'est à partir de 23
50 24 ça peut devenir bien plus
difficile mais ouais jusqu'à 20 enfin en
tout cas 2250 on va dire jusqu'à 22 2250
il est il est tranquille la dame prend
C8 dame prend6 dame prend
C8 il va falloir bien placer la dame
pour éviter les
perpètes il y a énorme réussite pour
pour Michou
ici
ok
F7 problme c'est que sur tour G1 elle a
raté c'est terrible de
rater terrible TER oubl le
mat ça arrive ça arrive d'oublier
mat c'est dommage mais ouais
c'était ça arrive un oubli
une absence elle a oublié le dame prang
de mat ouais
c'était avec peu de temps ça peut ça
peut
arriver ça peut faire tourner le match
ce genre de petits
événements ça peut arriver
malheureusement et ouais elle a raté ce
mat en un c'est dommage hein toute la
partie se détruit
là-dessus c'est très
dommage je dirais même c'est pas
possible
je dirais même c'est pas
possible bon le match
continue je suis en train de regarder
vérifier un
truc
ok bon c'est un étau de
maroxi il reste combien de temps 18
minutes il reste deux parties ça peut
faire mal à
Rica ça peut faire
mal
ah complexe petit rock céit super le
streaming avec Vlad merci à toi le
pouvoir merci merci
ah ben on a bien kiffé hein c'était
marrant
bon c'est maroxi classique
avec les pions C4 4 dans la
Sicilienne non non il prend
prendbnb petit chez moi j'ai pas trop de
place- qu'elle va ramener le cavalier en
C3 ou pas j'en sais rien
honnêtementêre une
idée
D4 pr D4 dame prend et peut-être B5
possible
ouis F4 c'était pas bien joué ça arrêtaé
de protéger la tour
C1
dame C5 prise il va vooir cavalier
prend excellente pause pour les Noirs
ouais ouais c'est pour ça en fait Arik
j'ai l'impression qu'elle joue mieux
globalementès c'est pas sûr qu'elle la
gagne hein
mais
c'est fou qui se fait victimiser par des
ouais il souffre
Mazo il joue sans
calculer al TR elle a fermé non mais ça
ça doit être ça ça doit pas être
suffisant pour pour vraiment poser de
gros problèmes faudra qu'elle réussisse
à peut-être faire E5 Caval e SK D4 mais
ce serait dangereux en
plus Mazo qui forme
ou c'est dur la reprise puis tu joues
avec le masque et tout ça fait des
choses
aussi ciao lesrelin passe passe une
bonne
journée peut-être à tout à l'heure
mais Jul qui a perdu contre solo hier
Jul il avait gagné très vite et
aujourd'hui il a perdu très
vite bizarre
fini deux fois deux fois rapidement il y
a quand même des surprises dans ce Top
12 dans dans les
parties une partie long le pourcentage
d'être en forme physiquement bah d'être
en forme et d'avoir envie de jouer ça
c'est important quand
même quiend deain qui a du stress ah bah
si ça te stresse trop ça reste un jeu
hein il faut
pas si tu prends pas de plaisir il faut
pas il faut pas s'embêter hein c'est le
seul conseil que je peux te
donner le président qui régale ouais je
crois qu'il était bien le président mais
après je je contre un mec qui a moins de
2003 non c'est quand même des des
différences de niveau les gars vous vous
rendez pas
compte c'est pas
c'est une guerre asymétrique
quoi la différence de niveau elle est
quand même immense
entre un
Baky compétion mix oui toutes les
compétitions sont
mixtes Gérald d'amum sauf les
compétitions féminine mais toutes les
compétitions sont mixtes
sinon
j'arrive pas à trouver la partie de Mazo
en fait depuis tout à l'heure je le
cherche pour me faire un
avis on aura recap non il y aura pas de
recap il aura rien mais mais juste par
curiosité pendant que je suis là
Mazo il est très très mal en
fait comment il fait ça
Mazo après peut-être qu'il a pas envie
de jouer hein
possible
j'ai vu quetien a joué une gr pe pas
vous des problèm à
Maxime le niveau des joueurs contre qui
joue peuvent pas pousser Baki à
dévoiler des
préparations c'est pas c'est pas
possible les joueurs sont beaucoup trop
faibles
en face pour que pour que Baky doive
dévoiler quoi que ce
soit contre un grand maître à 2650 ou
2007 je sais pas s'il le ferait aussi
mais ce serait
différent et d'ailleurs je suis pas sûr
que B
qui aurait joué le ré de Maxime parce
qu'il y a des variantes de nul
forcé non mais un mec à 2003 bah qui bah
c'estfin c'est n'importe quoi la
différence de niveau il peut y avoir des
surprises après mais il y a 40 monondes
d'écart mais Maxime joue pas si je crois
qu'il peut jouer théoriquement quelques
parties mais que dans les gros
matchs
non mais c'est pas du c'est pas des gros
adversaires que que B a ici on verra
après s' joue contre des des joueurs
plus
forts ce qu'
fait 2003 ça se fait pas battre à
l'aveugle si B qui l'aveugle est plus
fort qu'un joueur à 2300 Maxime lach
très
clairement ça c'est
sûr ça c'est sûr c'est sûr que que bah
qui joue mieux en fait ouais bah qui a
l'aveugle est plus fort c'est
sûr
ouais là il va y avoir FO à 3 et
cavalier
D6 je suis pas sûr et certain 3 c'est
solide même si notre président est fort
bah non je peux te dire que Baky à
l'aveugle est plus fort que moi si je
vois c'est très
clair et tu auras du mal mal d' trouver
un 2003 qui joue mieux du coup
euh mais c'est clair et net l'aveugle ça
enlève peut-être entre 100 et 200 points
ho pas beaucoup
plus par cont tour à8 sur Arc
B5 bon c'est un pion un gros pion de
plus avec le clouage en en en
B4 jour son niveau était quasi identique
à ouais c'est peut-être - 100- 200
points lo mais pas plus si on considère
que Baky joue à 2680 il va jamais jouer
à moins de 25 50 25 25 50 à
l'aveugle non non bah qui bah qui a
l'aveugle il B il B c'est pas
obligatoirement qu'il batte mais si tu
fais un match en 20 parties il va battre
un 2300 c'est
sûr
clairement
hein il B cornette à l'aveugle non
peut-être pas qu'il le ah je sais pas je
c'est dur à
dire sur beaucoup de parties quelle
quelle est le le la différence de niveau
entre un Bak à
l'aveugle et un Cornetto mais genre même
un Baky en 3 + 2 est censé être plus
fort qu'un 2300 et c'est plus difficile
de jouer en 3 + 2 que de jouer en à
l'aveugle parce que 3 + 2 censé te faire
perdre 300 300 points l ton niveau en 3
+ 2 est censé être 300 point l de moins
que ton
feed en
gros
donc même avec 3 minutes contre 2h bah
qui est censé mieux
jouer c'est un théorème un peu voilà ils
ont fait ça en étudiant des parties
quoi
on est en regardant un peu les parties
en faisant des comparatifs par
ordinateur ils avaient trouvé ça c'était
100 points de moins pour le rapide par
rapport à la longue et et 300 pour le
Blitz par
rapport par rapport à la longue je fait
passer ça un peu comme avec les caps
dans l'ordinateur et
cetera
non donc Baky Baky by domine
hein bah qui domine comme
Wesley est-ce que ça va être la dernière
partie de la cadence ou pas probablement
non on en aura encore
une
ah tu as BTU JG meilleur à l'Arena de
mercredi c'est bien il faut battre jor
meer malheureusement ça l'a pas empêché
d'aller jusqu'en
finale moi j'ai pris tellement cher j'ai
regardé joué quatre parties deux contre
un gars qui trichait et deux contre un
gars qui s bagué sévère ça m'a coûté la
calife en fait j'ai pensé avoir troll
mais en fait non j'ai joué correct juste
quatre trichurs dans une Arena ça a fait
trop ça a coûté
cher que sinon c'était pas mal ce que ce
que je faisais quand même mercredi
dernier j'ai pas eu de de bol
dernièrement avec la triche sur les
Arenas ça m'a coûté très
cher
tu devais refuser les nom titrés sans
photo ouais mais tu peux pas dans les
Arenas là il va y avoir descco pour D6 F
prend
B4 j'ai jou un trich une Arena ça est
grave démotivé bah moi là en deux Arenas
j'en ai joué là j'ai joué deux fois de
de deux fois de donc j'ai minimum joué
sur ouais les trois derniers Arenas au
minima 10 joueurs qui trichaient c'est
c'est ce qui m'a coûté la calife de deux
fois ça je suis d'accord avec toi c'est
assez
démotivant je suis 100 % avec d'accord
avec toi Maxime mais rien ne sera fait
contre donc il faut soit arrêter de les
jouer soit
elle a elle a oublié faut prend B4 oh
c'est terrible a pas vu la tour en un
Harik c'est dommage qu'elle aurait pu
faire tour B2 bon elle reste gagnante
mais dommage de pas avoir une tour en
un
et oui disons quand on joue un peu trop
après tu commences à trollle surtout que
j'avais très bien joué j'avais battu l
j'avais battu du
monde alors est-ce que on va avoir la
pause maintenant ou encore une partie
ouais non on va encore avoir une
partie
là il y a peut-être un plan marrant
c'est d'essayer de ramener le
roi pour manger la
tour et lames qui jou pas mal
ouais
j'ai pas compris ce qu'elle a fait avec
les Blancs honnêtement elle va pas la
gagner j'ai pas du tout compris ce
qu'elle a foutu
elle risque de ne pas
gagner 2 CIT spécial ouais ouais j'ai
pas j'ai pas du tout compris ce qu'elle
avait fait ou là cavalier B6 c'est troll
international
aussi terrible il fallait juste faire
tour B4
k B6 puis aller tomber
oh c'est terrible ces
erreurs terrible ou il y a eu le mat en
un raté là il y a
ça il y a du
troll
en un dragon hyper
accé fermé j'ai dans les TR du dragon
hyper accéléré le H4 là c'est un truc un
peu
bizarre B soirir le stade soulever le
bouclier mais lequel de stade
gravity
Mao qui est foutu vous dites faites
voir là il est complètement foutu
Mao c'est absolument terrible sa
position merci Galactic qui dit Liv
vraiment
bien est complètement
foutu
tout échang juste
[Musique]
regarder non si son adversaire trouve ça
abandon en fait il peut tout échanger
non l'adversaire de Mao peut se
retrouver avec une tour de plus en fait
en TR coups
ça va tropiss Sévre perdre contre un
joueur à
2000 à 2030 c'est quand même c'est quand
même
abusé
il y a que Fab qui joue
bien il n'y a que
Fab terrible il ont une position bizarre
là dans leur match
ouais non ma C il peut la perdre
malheureusement là son adversaire il a
une combine vraiment
contre je pense qu'il va gagner Maran tu
m'aurais demandé avant la partie
j'aurais pensé que Maran était favori
non maisil a il a les noir mais qu'il
avait un bon
Shot est pas trop en confiance il joue
pas super bien dernièrement et marquant
c'est
l'inverse en plus il a déjà je crois que
c'est un des premiers grand ma de
premier plan qu'il a battu en en rapide
marquant
contre romain ouais ça j'ai j'ai lu
ou mais Corneto après je suis assez
confiant parce que Orneto c'est un c'est
quelqu'un qui travaille beaucoup donc
normalement les gens qui travaillent
beaucoup ça les favorise plutôt les les
confinements et et ce genre de choses
ouais c'est une vraie bibliothèque
Corneto
ouis salut
PicoScope
allez il va y avoir du cavalier des CCO
peut-être et bah qui qui a gagné qui a
fait le
taf bah qui qui a fait le
taf
bahà de toute façon forcément ça ça
Nivelle tellement les niveaux ce
confinement parce que les grands matres
du coup ils ont moins moins travaillé
pendant la pause et peut-être que les
autres ont plus travaillé que d'habitude
donc forcément ça Nivelle ça Nivelle un
petit
peu
bon cette partie du coup se passe plôt
bien pour les blancs depuis tout à
l'heure vous pouvez le trouver sur
chess.com/ev bien
sûr nous on suivra peut-être un match
ensemble quand le quand le ministre joue
s'il y a des gros
matchs mais il nous faudrait un un
ministre il nous faudrait une présence
ministérielle
là ça le
fait va pousser au
centre avec du C3 du
F4 moi j'ai surtout hâte de la reprise
des sub battle ça va être beau ça la
compète allez F4 allez faut
envoyerin
la prochaine sub battle à proprement
dire avec les anciens formats ce sera
entre le 5 et le 12
juillet visuellement le 8 ah le 8 j'ai
ma vaccination
peut-être le 7 du coup ah mais le 7 il a
l'Arena Kings peut-être le 9
ant le 8 j'ai ma deuxième ma deuxième
dose de vaccin ça m'emps combien de
temps ça
c'est4 bizarre ben elle veut fermer le
jeu et garder F4 F5
hein un jour pas plus ouais donc si je
le fais mercredi matin vendredi soir je
devrais être
chaud mais la deuxième dose mais plus en
PLS que la première non
ou
pas ça dépend des gens beaucoup de gens
qui mettent
oui
ok moi je suis un requin éclairé
quoi elle va se faire contrer he
peut-être elle a elle a tout foutu sur
blanc elle donne toutes les cases noires
mousichou c'est chaud
maintenant
au taf un mec a fait sa seconde ce matin
il était sec et gelé là et pourtant
première était nickel bon on verra je
vais mettre la sub battle si je peux le
neu sinon
euh sinon le 7 he ou le
allez fou5
peut-être qui peut se
présenter ah non les pièces mineures des
Noirs sont meilleures salut MV only
fans maintenant tour G7 tour G8 pour
rentrer ça va faire
mal peêtre dame D8 dame prend H4 dans le
Range fou F4 bien
joué ça devrait payé pour
harika tour prend tour G6 bien joué
encore là elle joue très très bien
harika pour forcer dame
prend et peut-être faire tour G6 dame G7
allez dame G7 allez c'est très très très
bien
joué queainant c'est tour H8 fou C8 les
prochains
coups
T
h6ou et ça gagne
ouais bah si elle avait pas raté le mat
en tout à l'heure elle est elle est
nettement plus forte Harik à mon avis
là elle va faire les deux points
d'écart B gros avantage pour harika bon
les mecs on se fait une petite pause et
je reviens à tout de
suite
c'est
reparti
alors c'est parti pour combien de temps
cette fois on va remettre le timer 43
qu4 d'heure
allez allez 3 qu4 d'heure de 3 plus
1 là c'est fini pour
Mazo j'ai perdu ma bouteille d'eau
moi devoir aller la chercher j'ai la
mettre quelque
part Mazo qui a perdu aujourd c'est
terrible il est vraiment pas en
forme il est vraiment pas en
forme c'est toujours c'est genre des tau
de maroxi mais là le P est resté en E2
ce qui permet d'avoir le fou qui
brille
donc tour fd8 alors qu'est-ce qu'elle va
faire est-ce qu'elle va faire un dame1
pour cavalier D5 et prend F6 7 un
jour faire B4 Harik B5 et prend des6 ça
l'air
terrifiant pe-êre elle peut commencer
par K B5 fb4 après aussi possible pour
jouer l'enfermement de
dame
c'est bien joué
B4 je pense qu'elle va prendre H5
cavalier prend et tenter du cavalier
binco
est-ce que je streame ce soir bah je
vais peut-être faire un court
stream avant Lefin avant le rugby ouais
et après je vais regarder la finale de
Top 14
évidemment je peux pas
rater on va voir si elle fait
B5 c'est
joué on a joué le truc le plus
logique le foot au rugby le rugby de
très loin le problème c'est que ça
attaque D6 ça attaque
tout là c'est vrai que les les noirs
sont en grosse difficulté
il faut prendre des 5 elle a d oublier
elle est pas obligé de reprendre du
cavalier et T prend fou
prend et ça va le faire al qui peut
prendre trois points d'avance elle joue
beaucoup mieux
allez ça peut faire
l'écart ça peut faire
l'écart pour tous ou La Rochelle bon
j'ai pas de préférence de base mais je
pense que la Rochelle va gagner ce soir
faut faire gaffe
là il y a le cavalier D3 qui peut
arrivriver remar qu' prend 7 qui des TR
à tour D1 donc caver prend a 7 tour D7
il faut d ouais mais là laisse cavalier
F3 échec du
coup mais mais c'est peut-être pas
grave je disais ça aussi pour la finale
de la Coupe d'Europe ouais mais je
trouve que la Rochelle a mieux joué
après après après le stade a gagné parce
que à l'expérience et au fait jouer avec
le carton rouge et cetera mais je pense
que la Rochelle était était plus
forte après j'avais dit pour pour la
finale de Coupe d'Europe que je pensais
que c'était le Stade Toulousain qui
allait l'emporter donc je m'étais pas
trompé
mais je pensais que La Rochelle était
plus fort mais ça j'avais
senti je pense qu'elle va faire ro chin
plutôt pour avoir Foug de au cas où
plus logique mais tour des2 est fort là
ou parce que ça tour prend F2 la partie
qui a tourné je
pense la partie qui a
tourné
était plus forte j'ai dis plus faible
peut-être ouais parce que je fatigue un
peu là à
force très dur pour harika qui avait une
bonne position qui l'a pourri
elle-même alle prend G2 qui prend3 c'est
termine à
do il y a en plus le cavalier en B5 qui
tombe à la
fin
malin très malin
ça donc c'est pas fini C5
b68 ça ça va aller chercher de la la
mar8 bien joué
elle a joué quelques très bon coup
dommageis du cavalier peut-être
pour avoir l'option vraiment passé très
éloigné mais ça va faire nul
normalement maintenant c'est moins
sûr alors
attendez comment ça va
évoluer
ok il y a jamais de cavalier
F6 elle progresse petit à petit là Annna
gagne un pion encore je pense qu'elle va
vouloir essayer de sacrifier les deux
cavaliers
ouais mais ça ça marche pas
ah elle arrive à avoir roi G4 H6 ro
H5 roi prend
H6 et elle peut stand et roi prend G5 ok
joli nul il y a eu beaucoup de
retournement
donc donc donc donc ça fait quoi ça fait
53 elle refait
un genre d'attaque Grand
Prix
alexar je crois que tu es vraiment
matrixé par les
hello tu es matrixé par les hello
frérot c'est
terrible les gens ils jouent aux échecs
quoi enfin là il y a ça fait un an et
demi que ça va pas joué tu en as plein
qui sont peut-être pas rentrés il y a
trop de choses qui se sont passé entre
tempemps tu as peut-être des gars qui se
sont entraînés à fond pendant cette
année et demi pour revenir en forme
d'autres qui bah voilà qui son't fich ou
qui ont eu qui commenc à avoir d'autres
priorités dans dans leur vie que que de
pousser trois bouts de bois
quoi donc je sais pas tu vois c'est
c'est normal qu'il y a des surprises
dans ces périodes là et encore c'est des
surprises relatives parce que sur le
nombre de parties on a
forcément
il Vion prend des5 prend des 5 F G5 ça a
pas marché il y a F6 tout le temps ah
c'est bizarre ça passe pas avec les
Blancs ça moi j'aurais l'impression que
ça passe il y a pas mal de trucs qui
semblent être en prise avec des clouages
j'arrive pas à faire
marcher
elle va faire F6 prise D5 prise
D5 il fout des deux rois H8
ouais ça Maxime l un an et demi après ça
veut ça ça veut rien dire mais ça veut
moins dire
ok là faut calculer C4 puis on prend
cavalier prend puis on prend fout des5
cavalier prend cavalier reprend tour
D1 qui a l'air de marcher pour les
blancs
donc cavalier à 6 protège le
pion et
à4
donc A4 ça menace de dévier ouais ça
force un peu
B4 C4 bien joué sur fou prend dame prend
ça fait échec et ça gagne le
Caval leses dam des 6 aussi par que sur
fou pr c 5 c'était dame pr 5 échec du
coup elle doit le faire dans sens là et
maintenant tour8 pour tour 2 tour
C8 ça laisse B4 il va y avoir tour
B8 dame à
3 dame C6 dame C6
D4 dame C6 D4 et peut-être jouer pour
non pas G5 dur de trouver un bon coup
ici pour les Noirs après D4 qui est le
seul coup he
peut-être faire tour B8 et fou F8 mais
euh est-ce que tu as vraiment
envie
OK et à 5
OK du coup est-ce qu'elle peut faire F F
maintenant F c'était pour jouer sur le
clouage
ouais c'est fait dame prend à 5 F prend
C5 prise prise prise prise mais oui il y
a trois pion passés là ok ça c'est sûr
que c'est mort c'est tellement
fort
les pub c'est moi qui les place ah non
non c'est pas moi enfin moi j'ai aucun
rapport avec ça les gars vous me
connaissez hein j'en mets même pas sur
ma chaîne
donc mais oui bien sûr c'est terrible je
suis d'accord avec vous mais bon
après après c'est cool que ce soit
làdessus qui me c'est de c'est de faire
la Coupe du monde et qu'il fout de la
pub tout le temps s'ils font ça pendant
la coupe du monde je rchequitterai le le
live je je préfère le dire d'avance s'il
y a des pubs comme ça ambulant pendant
la coupe du monde je je rche kitte le
cast j'annonce
hein le rash kit
partira là c'est je enfin pour cette
compétition là tant pis enfin je m'en
fiche complètement en
fait mais pour la la Coupe du monde ça
n'aura pas lieu quoi ah là elle laisse t
prend G1 et F prend G2 t prend G2 r
prend D4 c'est raté faut les prévenir oh
bah ça ça va être fait je te rassure
hein ça je vais te dire au pire rage kit
et puis tant pis
hein ah là a raté une pièce en deux pas
de
chance non là ce match
là tu t'en fich ça sentit pas du tout
ouais on essaie de on fait ce qu'on peut
bar en
fou tu feras le live sur ta chaîne il y
aura trois fois plus de viewers ouais
mais bon fais pas toujours ce qu'on
veut mince j'ai mis
clic
mais oui là clairement de ce que je vois
quand les gens mettent qu' encore une
pub c'est un peu
abusé ah j'ai vu que le grand ch Magreb
se termine le 11 avec mvl et que la
Coupe du Monde démarre le 10 il y a un
problème non il y a un tour préliminaire
de Coupe du Monde et Maxime est qualifié
au 2iè
tour tu pouras nous expliquer les les
fonctions de la la Coupe du Monde oh
c'est c'est juste une coupe en fait là
pour la peine c'est hyper
simple là c'est hyper
simple non mais clairement c'est un peu
dommage de de mettre autant de pub
surtout que il y a je pense que dans les
gens qui suivent il y a beaucoup de gens
qui sont àos àos diamant sur chesscom et
et je suis d'accord que c'est c'est un
peu exagéré mettre les 6 minutes de pub
pendant la pause pourquoi pas mais les
mettre comme ça tout le long c'est un
peu c'est un peu relou quoi non non ça
n'aura pas lieu en ma présence pendant
la coupe du monde ça vous pouvez en être
je vous le
garantis ça je vous le garantis euh
c'est pas possible en fait
ou alors je retournerai sur ma chaîne et
puis euh puis j'aurai peut-être des
problèmes mais mais tant pis c'est pas
grave la commue avant
tout je prendrai un un sponso de boisson
énergétique et puis et puis le problème
c'est sera réglé hein c'est pas ça qui
manque tant pis
hein tant pis c'est comme ça
hein donc je dire oh bah au pire là il y
a F pr F6 et dame F4 ça gagne une pièce
instantanément Coupe du Monde c'est quel
niveau par Rapp au candidat bah il y a
tous les meilleurs hein Coupe du Monde
c'est magnifique
Solaris ça s'appelle une
pièce et
j'ai4
clouage non les sponsau de boisson
énergétique en plus
c'est le truc intéressant
là normalement Magnus et Yan consacrent
tout leur temps sur comment se
contrecarrer mutuellement ou c'est le
même type d'entraînement ouais ouais non
ils essayent de se contrecarer
mutuellement
ouais je dire celui qui gagnent
championnat du monde ne devient pas
champion ah non le la gagner la Coupe du
Monde permet de participer au candidats
qui permet de d'éventuellement aller au
championnat du
monde
ok c'est win c'est win pour harika bon
bonà c'est Dame prend G5 hein ah la
pièce est en
prise ça se
mange la Coupe du Monde c'est très sympa
ouais c'est quand la la prochaine
apparition de Vlad oh ça tu sais jamais
hein je me demanderais s'il y a pas du
F4 F2 tour Hachin pour aller mater
perso les prochaines compèes de mvl du
coup c'est c'est
du ça doit être le 6 ou le 7 j'imagine
et donc la finale de la Coupe du Monde a
comme seul intérêt l'argent oui et là
c'est G5 cavalier F6 c'est quand même un
titre honorifique aussi
hein mais globalement
oui ça fait plus partie du cycle pour
devenir champion du monde on va dire ça
comme ça c'est d'ailleurs sur une des
raisons pour lesquelles la plupart du
temps on suit pas vraiment la finale la
finale n'a pas vraiment d'intérêt
sportif comparé aux demi-final on va
dire les demi-finales sont sont comme
deux finales qui se joue en même temps
en réalité on peut dire qu'il y a deux
deux tournois sur la Coupe du monde le
tableau haut et le tableau
bas tellement désespéré la
pauvre il reste combien de temps cette
cadence 23 minutes encore
est-ce que j'ai déjà eu la série
objectif grand mare de la gardois il y a
des trucs bien
dedans
bon ça
repart ça repart sur une
carocane
le répertoire facile
ouais répertoire très facile avec
CCO
sur pour fa passer le
temps passe petit à petit
hein veut dire que ça passe plus très
vite
làs
5h15 on su un peu quoi cétait censé
finir à
19h mais ça va finir un peu en retard ça
fait plaisir hein ça fait un peu plus
d'échec de haut niveau à suivre c'est du
bonheur
ah encore une petite pub quand même qui
part c'est dommage que je les ai pas moi
les pubs j'aimerais bien les voir en
même temps que
vous
j'ai vu
autant part je m'étais fait défoncer
après le les candidats parce que j'en
avais pas mis assez donc là vous avez le
ratio de pub qu'on aurait dû avoir pour
les
candidats là ce que vous avez maintenant
c'est ce qu'on aurait dû
avoir quand on suivait les
candidats
ça avait pas été
fait ça n'avait pas été fait parce que
j'avais pas c'était du coup c'est plus
moi qui m'en
occupe c'était pas très bien
passé heureusement c'est pas Paris sur
ouais ben écoute
fou3 au candidat ça aurait été chiant
mais c'est la Coupe du Monde c'est
pareil c'est autant de pub juste je rage
kit c'est fini n'en parle plus
hein
donc après pour pour la Coupe du Monde
vous pouvez toujours prendre un SAB
aussi quoi il a aussi cette option là
pour ces matchs là prendre un sub ça
fait un peu mal quand
même je sais pas s pas y avoir un tour
D7 quelque chose comme
ça il aur fous
6 pour fer des S abonn ch com ouais
c'est vrai qu'il y a un peu ce cette
problématique ouais c'est différent qui
c'était qu'une chaîne là tu as le côté
aussi de chesscom abonnement et tout
donc oui je comprends aussi ton
argument
j'ai l'air claqué bon ça va je me
défends bien Kandl
style franchement je regarde mon retour
caméra je me défends très très bien
après je suis un peu claqué mais c'est
pas spécial pour cette journée c'est
plus je crois que c'est mon 26e ou 27e
jour de stream d'affilé demain
après-demain je streame pas en tout cas
pas pas pass mais lundi j'ai SPE fémin
encore ça me frustre de
ouf
magnifique cam de harrya
ouais la semaine prochaine ça va être
dur il y a encore 4
matchs
complexe h peut-être dame C6
ouais je ferais bien un petit dame
D7 dame prend des7 puis on prend des7
échecs
marlou c'est semi marlou hein mais
bon c'est beau quoi P4 qui est
venu qui est venu faire de la pub pour
un autre stream quoi c'est
magnifique t'inquiète pas il y aura
personne qui suivra non plus
AP4 ne t'inquiète pas frérot
ok est-ce qu'elle va réussir à gagner
ça
normalement non
la raison de venir défendre ça peut
faire même un peu peur elle va pouvoir
installer sa dame sur
F1 terrible de faire de la pub cel style
ouais après c'est les technique
marketing un peu de la pub sur les chats
et tout
ça ne changera
rien ça va est-ce que ça peut faire
petite
poussette pas vraiment pas vraiment
parce qu'elle va se faire récupérer le
pion commentaires ah j'ai beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de commentaire
malheureusement matastro avant de
pouvoir revenir sur ce qui me plaît
parce qu'après on va enchaîner ça puis
on va enchaîner la Coupe du Monde bon la
Coupe du Monde c'est quand même sympa et
quand même ça va faire pas mal de
soirées ouais le roi qui oh non par roi
F6 il f prend H5 ah c'est terrible de
laisser fou prend H5 oh c'est terrible
de pas le prendre
mais attendz il avait prend a non je dis
des
conneries non non ça va ça va par qu'en
fait c'est bien nul depuis tout à
l'heure avec B8 pr j'avais peur qu'elle
les raté mais non non c'est dro dro chez
dro hop encore une DRAO allez ça drô de
partout il reste combien il reste 14
minutes allez ça a un peu resserré les
niveaux
ça
continue ça marrant sur
l'archie
c'est moins seré qu'ier non hier le
match c'est plus serrié
qu'hierinarchi me font
marrer
pas nous suiv sur lit chasse demain oh
là c'est tous les sites qui ont décidé
de venir se faire de la
pub en fait ils ont fait
chess.com/events du coup qui est devenu
le meilleur site pour suivre des
parties donc en vrai c'est peutêtre
juste tu es pas au courant mais
maintenant
avec.com/ tuas les tu as très clairement
la meilleure plateforme pour pour suivre
en direct des parties donc non non c'est
ils ont réussi à faire évoluer le
truc c'est c'est pas de
chance donc vous
TR il va y voir c'est quoi trop qui va
arriver
non.c/ c'est vraiment
cool avant c'était pas terrible et
maintenant qu'ils ont mis ça en place
c'est vraiment
cool va réussir à mettre la pression une
nouvelle
fois c'est clair
il y a il y a un speedrun lundi soir moi
jeis exploser après le le speed ch
féminin mais je sais pas si ça vous dit
que je le tente c'est un speedrun en
bullette ça peut être
marrant c'est un event sympa dommage que
je que ce que je puisse le jouer
qu'après 3hur de speedess féminin donc
je serais pas à 100 % mais j'ai j'ai
bien envie de le
tenter
B les blancs sont mieux là il y a un
pion isolé pour les
Noirs d'ailleurs les speedrun s les fais
en 3 + 0 ce serait mieux que les Arenas
ça réglerait le
problème j'ai pensé à un truc comme ça
en fait cet event ça réglerait le
problème du S bag dans les Arenas
puisque tout le monde commence à 1200 et
il faut monter le plus haut possible en
quelques heures s'il faisait ça euh s'il
faisait ce
format au lieu des Arenas en fait ça
permettrait d'éviter le problème du SBAG
et donc ça améliorait grandement
le le
délire après je suis pas très bon
bulette faudrait que je m'entraîne un
peu
oh ça fait plaisir si une pub qui est
repartie
je demand ça pourrait être partie
intéressante ça pourrait prendre ses
propres pièces euh oui ça pourrait se
faire ça pourrait changer quelques
trucs
bizarre de pas venir par TR je pensais
qu'elle voulait partir comme ça en fait
moi je regardais ce
plan ah fouprend G6 cavalier E6 ah elle
va la rater je pense ah mais il y a
peut-être foupran et cavalier F4 fut F5
et il prend
G2 je pense faut quand même rentrer
dedans
du vu du spec c'est trop rapide ouais
mais après là c'est un speedrun c'est
c'est sur 3h baron fou et puis en plus
il y a France Suisse à 21h donc
peut-être je jouerai que 2h si je suis
pas dans les
premiers bizarre de pas avoir vu fprang
G6
mais ça peut être sympa comme petit
event surtout que tu vas voir tous les
gars qui Stream qui jouent ensemble donc
ça va être un speedrun complexe on peut
tomber sur du Ikaru en bullette ou des
gens comme ça
quoi faudra être très
malin ça va encore faire une draw mais
ça rate des tactiques faciles le foupr
G6 c'était quand même un énorme cadeau
ça trollle ça trollle ça trollle de
ouf ça trollle de
ouf
non elle veut essayer peut-être B4 et
cavalier ici qui C5
ramener le cavalier en
e5êre ça
ça faut mettre le en D3 c'est bizarre ro
D3 c'est terrible de pas jouer le G avec
les Blancs
ok j'ai eu
peur
un cavalier B3 qui C5 qu'est-ce qu'elle
fait ah ça rend fou oh ça me rend fou
non mais faire le nul là ça me rend fou
en fait
ou tu fais tu bouges ton fou et tu fais
cavalier F3 qui prend
H4 oh non c'est pas possible de faire
nul ici c'est pas possible de faire nul
ici ah non non non non non non non non
non non non heureusement que je regarde
tranquille depuis tout à l'heure parce
que dès qu'on va un peu s'impliquer dans
les games ça va me rendre fou c'est un
genre de sub battle géant quoi ah c'est
un genre de sub battle
géant
oh ils m'ont fait suer
oh non non non pas jouer le gain là les
amis heureusement que je regarde que
d'un œil sinon entre toutes les
tactiques raté et et
les et les passages comme ça ça rendrait
fou
c'est terrible cétait terrible après il
y a la fatigue la pression aussi qui
joue mais bon c'est dommage on aurait pu
voir une belle finale
technique ça gâche un peu les munitions
bah ça raté le fou G6 techniquement
c'est pas au
point battle on se fait défoncer ah oui
ça tu te fais défoncer en battle de pas
jouer
mais sub battle c'est marrant parce
qu'on est impliqué
émotionnellement quand tu as pas
vraiment d'implication c'est c'est
terrible
hein c'est absolument
et les gros tournois sont tous mixtes
pour répondre je réponds une 10è fois à
cette question mais ils sont tous
mixte ils sont absolument tous
mixte normal mal
hein
normalon alors comment ça va tourner
celle-là
il reste 426 ça peut être la dernière
partie de la cadence Annna qui est pas
mal une nouvelle fois a du dame do la
déposition ah ça peut-être déjà été dit
mais apparent Mazo avait les Noirs ah
bah ça
rassure et Nino les
blanc HM intéressant Robin c'est vrai
que Robin side donne une info
intéressante c'est vrai que CIT étonnant
la défaite de Mazo surtout que les coup
était bizarre mais bon après il a
tellement mal joué
hier et Nino les blancs c'est aussi plus
logique
ou là t
C1 dame
4 cavalier 4 il va falloir la sauver la
dame parce que K C3 normalement tu sors
pas trop mais il y a peut-être du G5
ouais il y a sûrement une erreur c'est
juste que les coups étaient bizarres
pour
duo c'est pas la manière dont il per
parti
quoi
bien joué cavalier
F5 bien
joué qu' prend 8 d' prend le 3 je
pense ok ça échange
part4 prend ici
prend ici elle va reprendre B6 maisura
en l'air mais le temps de faire F F3
récupère B7 pardon et sur D4 fou
F3 D 3 F3 il y a pasura
pas j'aime bien
dame F2 maintenant D4 il
faut CER prend D4 et qui prend G2
peut-être je peut-être qu'il a peut-être
fou prend F3 ah mais fou F3 qui prend F3
d prend F3
elle force la finale mais bon il y a
encore du Fou
H6 pour aller taper
F4 Caval C5 fout des5
ok ça peut ça peut clut pour Harik lui
donner trois points
d'avance et ici tour C8
ouais ça a l'air d'être difficile à
jouer pour les blancs les blancs sont
peut-être encore objectivement mieux
mais euh j'ai l'impression que c'est les
noirs qui vont gagner en
fait tellement dur à jouer
ça il joue vite en plus
elle va prendre H2
encore ça peut vraiment tuer le match en
fait
ça peut vraiment tuer le match
ça allez H5 G5 il faut envoyer il reste
20 secondes ici est-ce que ça va être la
dernière partie de la cadence pas sûr
pas sûr un fou prend F3 ambulant pour
forcer à l'abandon c'est pas joué donc
ce sera la dernière partie de la
cadence et oui
elle va avoir un immense avantage a
peut-être pas envie de donner la paire
de fou ok maintenant elle est un tout
petit danger bon c'est que ouais il a
puion passer de l'autre côté mais le
truc c'est que ça arrive tellement vite
là oh fou des5 peut-être un peu dommage
c'est H3 H2 H1 ça file à Dame tout seul
le truc c'est que ça ça file à Dame
aussi tout seul et H2
H1
etichu qui peut abandonner ouais et ça
fait ça fait TR points d'écart les amis
ouais c'est un gros écart bon sur ce euh
bah petite pause et après on vient pour
les bullettes à tout de suite les
gars
bon les mecs il reste plus que 25
minutes terrible après on va pouvoir
enfin faire quelques petits
Blitz on va voir harika qui a été
beaucoup plus fort sur tout le match on
va voir si elle réussit à gagner allez
ça part il reste 25
minutes après je sais pas je vais
essayer d'envoyer quelques petits Blitz
mais je pense à pas être possible je
voulais bliter avant avant le avant la
finale de
Top Top
tranquillement bon ça Contin à jouer les
petits systèmes avec le fou en B2 on va
essayer de mettre la tour en C1 la tour
en d en voyer
C4 pour qui je suis plutôt pour
harika en fait j'aime bien quand il y a
des gros
écarts et là on sent qu'arik elle peut
faire la
DIF ah au rugby euh bon écoute j'aime
bien les deux équipes après je te cache
pas que de base je serais plutôt été
pour le Stade Toulousain mais je suis
pas non plus supporter du stade et là
comme La Rochelle enfin je trouve qu'il
mérite donc je suis plutôt pour la
Rochelle parce que ils font une grosse
saison ils ont une grosse équipe ils ont
jamais gagné le Brenus je crois en tout
cas et donc euh et donc ça me ferait
plaisir pour eux qu'il l'emporte en
vrai
je suis toulousain mais ouais La
Rochelle mérite un titre après j'imagine
quand tu es supporter tu prends le
titre même même même même si mérite tu
es content que ton équipe
gagne bon se passe plutôt bien ça
pour pour Michou c'est important pour
elle de
gagner et vous pensez que La Rochelle
ils vont pouvoir se maintenir à un tel
niveau il y a pas mal d'équipes comme ça
qui font une deux grosses saisons et
puis après qui retourne dans le rang je
pense à
castre qui a pu très bien jouer sur une
de saisons mais qui a pas pu tenir le
rythme
elle est revenue dans la partie Arik
est elle est revenue dans la game
ouais c'est c'est pas clair de
nouveau il y a pas F3
ici ça a été raté par Michou le clouage
ouais mais F PR4 dame G3 puis on prend
D5 ah bizarre de pas avoir pris en D5 il
y a beaucoup d'échanges d'mabilité
ici dame F2 ça dame1 ouais pourquoi pas
ramener la dame en
H4 ça va sûrement gagner
ici pour pour harika et ça ça clutch ça
c'est clutch
total ça c'est clutch total parce
qu'elle était moins bien elle passe à +
4 la partie a duré 3 minutes 30 ouais je
pense le match est terminé ici plus 4 et
en plus c'est la joueuse qui joue le
mieux qui a retourné
je pense que c'est gagné faut être pour
pour qui tu veux là on s'en fiche total
mais mais ouais là ça
clutch là ça
clutch
bizarre de retourner en C7 et pas aller
en
D4 qui est pour
anre pas la
même j'arrive pasouver de l'intérêt pour
ce tournoi c'est terrible c'est
difficile ouais
c'est difficile parce que
ouis
enfin je sais pas j'ai c'est normal en
fait c'est normal en fait on a trop de
tournois intéressant avec Maxime avec
avec les les candidats avec avec la
Coupe du Monde qui arrive
même les grandes chais tour Paris ils
sont un peu un peu moins intéressants
entre guillemets et là il y a tour pr c
2 et dame D3 tour C8
ah qui marche peut-être
pas qui marche peut-être pas dame D3
dame ro C1 tour C8 F C3 dame 3 roi
B1 fou D3 elle a bien calculé là roi 1
tour C6 HM là elle a très bien calculé
harika ça j'aurais pas vu dans ma
mauvaise forme actuelle
ouais ben si elle clutche même
ça là ça va complètement tuer le
match et tour C6 ouais très très bien
joué et il y a pas de mat de l'utre côté
c'est
sûr faut tenter damage 7 ro bouge dame
G7 ro prend tour échec r vient échec
tour8 ouais abandonne et ouais ça fait
ça fait plus 5 il reste plus que 18
minutes 30
termado c'est
terminado c'est
GAM terrible
terrible
c'est vraiment
terrible c'est vraiment terrible mais
ouais vraiment
dominé cavalier H4 cavalier
F5
ah là il y a B4 à5 ça gagne une pièce
elle a pas vu
elle n'a pas vu le fou enfermé
thématique on apprend ça à l'école mais
bon bullette ça peut
arriver ça va faire plus 6 mais encore
harica je trouve que ouais elle a pas
forcément été même bien payé sur
l'ensemble du match
ouais le score est largement mérité là
il du Fou C4 aussi qui menace
ouais AB AB fou C4 ça fait mal
ok j'ai ça du coup attaque
là on va pouvoir
peut-être prendre 4 pour protéger le fou
prendre à 7 mettre le fou en C4 pour
attaquer
là mett le F en G5 puion F6 ah il encore
tour F8 pe F4 du
coup elle fait F H6 et tour 1 oh c'est
bien joué ça c'est joli tour à8 elle va
rentrer il y a plus de coup pour les
noir F D3 pas mal
la fou prend B5 aussi qui est pas mal
cavalier G5 est bien
aussi et ça fait plus
6 bon bah là il y a plus à assz de de
temps même pour remonter mais ça sentait
depuis un moment he carka était plus
forte c'est jamais serré ben an ù il fan
B là Rik ça se voyait aussi plus
forte c'est le format qui est comme ça
format 7 est toujours serré parce qu'en
fait tu dois gagner la dernière partie
pour gagner le match enfin même quand
c'est pas serré en fait euh ok tu peux
dire il peut y avoir un clutch un retour
ou
quoi la nature même du format donne ce
genre de de match
ok là elle va jouer euh
tour D4 tour H4 dam
H6 plus non c'était pareil c'est parce
que tu te rappelles que des matchs
serrés c'est pour ça mais l'année
dernière le speedch féminin les matchs
duraient 1h de donc ils étaient moins
long il y en avait beaucoup plus mais
ils étaient moins
long en fait ce qui se passe c'est qu'on
a compris après 1 heure 1h de que Harik
était plus forte et dans un format plus
ou moins normal le match aurait été
terminé à ce moment-là il y aurait eu
elle aurait peut-être gagné 2
7-0 en fait premier set serré 2uxè set à
un moment donné elle aurait pris la le
le devant mais euh mais en fait avec ce
format là les matchs sont à rallonge et
donc ça ça dure pour ça dure longtemps
pour rien en
fait
dame tour 3 dame 1 dame
D8 d 8 elle va
faire je pensais qu'elle ferait d 8 pour
couvrir
ok pour le moment il y a pas de ma mais
le truc c'est qu'elle a rien avec les
Noirs
ok dame prend F2 mais ça menace pas de
perpète ah sur D7 la fou prend D7 dame
prend dame G3 dame G1 et on sent que mou
ça l'a fait suer en
fait
je pense elle va remettre le r G5 non
ou là là ça
donne j'ai 5 c'est bizarre comme coup
mais ok j'ai 5
G4 l' fait
suer d F6 fou
G6 d H8 3 G5 dame 5 3 h6
il y a rien avec les noir c'est
horrible elle peut pas créer une seule
menace D3 D7 bien joué là il y a pas
moyen de faire une menace qui a jamais
de
F3 allez ça revient à 5
points ça revient à 5
points
on va voir comment ça ça se passe 5. 12
minutes allez il a peut-être encore une
micro
chance j'y crois pas du tout mais
bon B8 avir du qu trop
peut-être
attendez je vais écrire pour
m'inscrire pour le truc de
lundi
je suis surpris du score ouais non elle
a mieux joué François
Jacques honnêtement sur le contenu elle
était devant Harik mais M déjà dernier
elle étaitik moi je touj trouvé qu'elle
était forte dans ce
format là elle va se faire défoncer par
contre ah elle a une défense avec H4
puis on prend ro H2 mais il faut qu'elle
supprime le
cavalier
je sais plus qui c'est qui avait gagné
l'année dernière mais l'année dernière
c'était en forme de Grand Prix avait une
grande finale et je me rappelais je me
rappelle plus HM elle veut pion prend
dame D5 on va faire dame D5 quand même
je
pense et reprendre deux pour jouer la
case
4 allez tour 1 peut-être
D15 c'est pas mal ce qu'elle fait la
Rica elle est elle joue bien là quand
c'est
dynamiqueou va venir en
F5 elle provoque C6 mais C6 c'est un
coup utile pour les Noirs oh il y avait
G6 qui avit prend F8 c'était game
terrible elle a raté ça cé terminé
instant ah grosse erreur mais bon elle
avait plus temps 8 secondes
elle a raté une occase
ouais c qui avait super bien joué l'an
dernier cette année moins elle avait été
impressionnante je sais pas pourquoi
elle a pas été invitée cette année
d'ailleurs peut-être elle été invitée à
la
refusé h bien joué ça
elle a intérêt à faire nul en fait Arik
elle a de l'avance et
bon après là c'est une partie qui dure
he ça l'avantage
largement plus ça dure mieux c'est pour
elle mais après elle est perdante mais
elle peut elle peut faire couler elle
peut faire couler beaucoup de
temps partie à 4 minutes hein c'est une
partie qui est partie pour durer mais
attention là il y a C D4
cavalier2 et c'est mant de allez faut
jouer la pendule ah c'est bien ça ça
joue la pendule à
fond un jouer non même
pas allez c'est bien fait de sa part
plus 4 points 3 minutes 3 parties en 8
minutes tac tac tac c'est
impossible joué vraiment bien l'an
dernier
le cash Price c'Est à 66000 dollars en
tout c'est
beau la tête du
Gess
ouais c'est propre 66000 c'est propre
hein ah oui fan me B stban wiifan est un
peu plus forte que moi de toute façon il
suffit juste de regarder les chessc elle
tourne plus aux alentours de 28 28 50
moi plutôt 27 50 28 donc wiifan plus
forte que moi 100 %
sûr il y a pas de il y a pas
d'hésitation là Rica est en train de
full troll
le
Bullet se laisse attaquer je va par là
qu'elle doit normalement juste fermer le
match même avec les
bulette bah je suis pas très bon en
bulette
hein en vrai Harik elle pourrait poser
des problèmes Michou je pense moins dans
ce format là mais harika aussi sera
serait pas
facile
que je vois qu'elle voit elle est elle
est bien en tactique
elle est vraiment bien en
tactiqueend et F7 cavalier3 et cavalier
éche prend alors
que quoi
elle avait pas vu
ou avait pas vu Caval 3 voit des choses
j'avais un bon surtout que il y a un
boost de
30050ou point j'aurais eu l'équivalent
de00 si je m' entraînais oui
là c'est vraiment fini Michou a a choqué
a choquer la
dame mais elle était trop faible en
tactique par rapport à Rik elle rate
trop de
trucs B je jouer 1-0 lundi du coup pour
le chest down
quick ça va ça va jouer au hasard
hein
donc et c'est qui c'est Osma costenuk la
dernière
demi si je me trompe
pas
donc je regarde j'essaie de
trouver la dernière la dernière demi
dernier quart
tu sa meilleure chaîne twitch après
ouais mais pas très longtemps juste
histoire de se décompresser l'esprit là
par que 6h de speitch là ça ça a fait
mal je vais mettre les clips on fera une
petite heure de Live
ensemble
ah je retrouve
pas tout le monde en blitz non ouais
ouais ENF vite fait là quand même he
c'est sa qui domine tout le monde en
blitz j'ai 300 sub à donner
oh ça ferait
plaisir ah si tu les donnes ici c'est
vrai que tu remplis tu remplis les SAES
de tout le monde tiens je vais remettre
la pub de 3 minutes d'ailleurs histoire
de l'avoir de l'avoir faite au moins
c'est fait il voit qu'il y a beaucoup de
pub ils vont être contents et on
essaiera d'en avoir defin on en aura
moins pour la Coupe du monde où ce sera
sans mois enfin on peut en avoir 6
minutes mais par page de 6 minutes
quoi ah non ils ont envoyé une pub déjà
ils ont déjà renvoyé une
pub B il reste combien de temps il reste
250 après
ça
allez faut que ça joue un peu pour être
bien sûr qu'après ce soit la
dernière allez on va
partir non mais je pense pas que notre
ami est vraiment les 300 subs à donner
je pense qu'il trollle les
gars
qui va gagner
cellelà on ne sait jamais
un
peu il a raison ça occupe
elle joue elle joue jusqu'au bout pour
être bien sûr elle doit pas avoir le
timer TR mat et allez la
last
ka favorite pour le titre ouais je pense
je pense que le match de sera sympa en
demi cétait
contre ce sera sympa en fait la demi ka
sera
cool donc je envoyer quelques clips
comme ça je vais aller boire un petit
coup je vais essayer de faire des je
suis pas sûr d'y
arriver sa chance pour le titre
na pas vu la tête de harika
non allez encore une minute de
match c'est mathématiquement fini depuis
un
moment
elle a vraiment à la Westley elle a
gagné le match à la Westley
Arica sur la domination
ou prend C4 t reprend D1 ça marchait
aussi ou t prend des2 et prend C4
l'autre était plus fort mais ça ça gagne
aussi faut terminer le
boulot ça va échanger bon c'est pas sûr
qu'elle gagne mais bon de toute
façon c'est complètement anecdotique les
amis et ben voilà c'est terminé
officiellement gagner ce
match je vais commencer à préparer le
raid et j'enverra je enerel qu clips
avant on partira sur quelques clips et
je viendrai pour biter une petite
heure allez on attend impatiemment la
fin de cette
partie qui clôturera l'aventure pour
Michou oh ça mérite de remettre une
petite pub hein j'envoie déjà la pub on
va réussir en remettre encore 3 minutes
pour être bien
sûr histoire bien d'être bien
sûr attends pass la fin de la partie bah
le match est finiin du
coup
avec le contrat de CHC je vas bien avec
ma chaîne twitch en fait en
vrai en vrai pas
trop dans un moment ça m'était
indispensable et maintenant c'est plus
le cas c'est plus plus comme
avant après j'aime bien commenter les
tournois quand on a les caméras et tout
mais mais mais la fin des speed là c'est
un peu un peu complexe quoi
ouis c'est plus qui a besoin de enrai
plus ça
maintenant bon mais là en fait ouais tu
fais le tu fais la même chose bon on
envoyer le RA tu fais la même chose avec
un format mieux le match est 1000 fois
mieux c'est gagné pour Harik qui a l'air
d'être heureuse
et fatigué en même temps bon allez à
toutite